I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Welcome everybody to the email surveillance episode of Office, ladies. Howdy.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎，欢迎大家收看办公室女郎的电子邮件监控那一集。大家好。
It is season two, episode nine, written by Jen Salata, directed by Paul Feigen. We have a special guest in the studio with us today. He played Bill, one of the members of Michael Scott's improv class. It is our friend, Ken Jong. Hey guys. Thank you so much for having me. We are so excited you are here. You are our second in-studio guest.
这是第二季第九集，由简·萨拉塔编剧，保罗·费格执导。今天我们的演播室来了一位特别嘉宾。他饰演了比尔，迈克尔·斯科特即兴表演班的成员之一。他是我们的朋友，郑肯。嗨，伙计们。非常感谢邀请我来。我们很高兴你能来。你是我们的第二位演播室嘉宾。
Yes. You and Creed Bratton, Ken. That is privileged company. So I'm very, very excited to be here. So seriously. Thank you guys. And congrats. Congrats on the success of your podcast.
是的。你和克里德·布拉顿，肯。那是相当尊贵的嘉宾阵容。所以我非常非常高兴能来到这里。真的。谢谢你们。祝贺你们。祝贺你们的播客取得成功。
I listened to it and it's awesome. So thank you for having me. Thanks, Ken. And this is Ken's day off. And I mean, you're a busy, busy person. I can't even get into the mass singer and what it means to my children and how much we have to talk about it. That's a whole other subject.
我听过了，非常棒。所以谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢，肯。今天是肯的休息日。我的意思是，你是一个非常非常忙碌的人。我甚至都不想谈《蒙面歌王》以及它对我的孩子们意味着什么，还有我们必须讨论它多少次。那是另一个话题了。
Sure, sure. But you're a busy guy and we appreciate you coming in on your day off. Oh no. Thank you. So, Ken, to this episode, you two have known each other for a very long time. When did you guys become friends? You did a movie together. I think, really, Ken, what crystallized our friendship was your 40th birthday.
当然，当然。但你是个忙人，我们很感激你在休息日抽空过来。噢，不。谢谢你们。肯，说回这一集，你们俩认识很久了。你们是什么时候成为朋友的？你们一起拍过一部电影。我想，真的，肯，让我们的友谊定格的是你的40岁生日。
Was it your 40th birthday? It was my 40th birthday. Your 40th birthday. Yeah. Okay. So he's twisting in his chair. He literally is about to fall out of a chair. I don't know this story.
是你的40岁生日吗？那是我的40岁生日。你的40岁生日。对。好吧。所以他在椅子上扭动着身体。他简直快要从椅子上摔下来了。我不知道这个故事。
Okay. So, you know, Ken had done the office, but we didn't work together that day. Our paths never crossed. Right. And then years later, we're on hiatus from the office and I am going to be playing this role on a movie called Furry Vengeance. Brooke Shields was in it. Yes.
好吧。所以，你知道，肯演过《办公室》，但那天我们没有一起工作。我们的轨迹从未交错。没错。然后多年后，我们从《办公室》剧组休假，我要去参演一部名为《毛茸茸的复仇》的电影。布鲁克·谢尔兹也在里面。对。
Brendan Frazier. I was such a huge Brendan Frazier fan. Me too. Oh my gosh. We were filming in the middle of nowhere, Massachusetts, day one. I think we were like two doors apart on our floor. Yeah, no. We were on the same floor.
布兰登·弗雷泽。我是布兰登·弗雷泽的超级粉丝。我也是。噢，天哪。我们在马萨诸塞州荒凉的中部拍摄，第一天。我想我们在那一层的房间大概只隔了两扇门。对，不对。我们在同一层。
I think we were across from each other. We're across the hall. We're across the hall at the Radisson. Oh my gosh. This is so cute. I come out of my room. Ken comes out and I'm like, hey, you picked the Radisson too. We're like that.
我想我们俩在走廊的正对面。我们在大堂对面。我们在雷迪森酒店的走廊两端。噢，天哪。这太可爱了。我走出我的房间。肯也出来了，我说，嘿，你也选了雷迪森。我们就像那样。
We're the only two actors. Yeah. We're the only two actors in the Radisson with the crew. So we just would hang out all the time. We were always in the shuttle together. We became pretty fast friends right away. Very fast friends. And that first week was Ken's 40th birthday and here he is away from his family.
我们俩是唯一的演员。对。我们在雷迪森酒店里仅有的两个演员，和剧组住在一起。所以我们总是整天黏在一起。我们总是一起坐班车。我们很快就成了好朋友。非常快就成了好朋友。第一周正好是肯的40岁生日，而他当时却远离了家人。
You were a little sad about it. And we didn't have a car because we were on location. We had the day off. Our day off happened to be his birthday together, him and I. I said, you know what? I'm going to take you out for your birthday. And from the Radisson there was a, we were sort of up on a hill and you could see down the hill, down a big steep hill in this parking lot was a PF Changs.
你当时有点难过。而且我们没有车，因为我们在外景地。我们那天休息。我们的休息日恰好是他的生日，我和他在一起。我说，你知道吗？我要带你出去过生日。从雷迪森酒店望出去，我们当时好像在山坡上，你能顺着山坡往下看，沿着那个陡峭的大坡，在一个停车场里有一家P.F. Changs（华馆）。
And I said, Ken, I'm taking you to PF Changs for your birthday. Amazing. I don't know why we didn't want to get a cab, but we walked it and it wasn't like it was connected in the parking lot. At one point we had to like crawl a little bit through a grassy median thing. Remember? It was like the parking lot was separated by like a little bit of a grassy knoll. Anyway, we walked down this parking lot.
我说，肯，我要带你去P.F. Changs过生日。太棒了。我不知道为什么我们不想叫辆出租车，但我们走着去了，那可不是停车场直接连着的。有一会儿我们甚至得在一片草地中间稍微爬一下。还记得吗？那个停车场被一小片草丘隔开了。不管怎样，我们穿过这个停车场。
We go into PF Changs at like 11 a.m. There's no one, there's like no one there. We're the first people there. We ate so much and drank a ton of beer and we were both really buzzed. And now we have to walk up this hill and we're like tipsy and we're like, oh my God, this hill sucks on the way back. And Ken was like, what did you do to me, my 40th birthday? Okay, you just decided mid-walk like, hey, I should just exercise and you're like walking
我们在早上11点左右走进了P.F. Changs。里面空无一人，简直一个人也没有。我们是第一批客人。我们吃得超级多，喝了成吨的啤酒，我们俩都喝得飘飘然了。然后我们得爬上这座山，我们有点微醺，我们俩都在想，天哪，回去的时候这座山太折磨人了。肯就说，你对我的40岁生日做了什么？好吧，你就在半路上突然决定说，嘿，我应该锻炼一下，然后你就开始
around the parking lot like you're doing laps. I said, pump your arms, Ken. And then you were literally speed walking drunk at a Radisson parking lot. Just remember, you're just, you know, there's a hill. I was like, Ken, pump your arms. Come on. Pump your arms. We're gonna get a workout.
绕着停车场走，就像在跑圈一样。我说，肯，摆动你的手臂。然后你就在雷迪森酒店的停车场里醉醺醺地快走。记住，你只是，你知道的，有个上坡。我当时就说，肯，摆动你的手臂。来吧。摆动你的手臂。我们要锻炼一下。
And I was just crying, laughing. You were crying, laughing so hard. You were like, what are we doing? What are we doing? And you turned to me. Come on, Ken. Pump. Pump.
我当时笑得眼泪都快出来了。你笑得眼泪直流。你一直在说，我们在干什么？我们在干什么？然后你转过身对我说。来吧，肯。摆动。摆动。
You're making us off topic. All right. Focus, Jenna. How about a summary? In this episode, Michael gains access to everyone's emails and discovers that Jim is hosting a barbecue. Everyone except Michael has been invited. Michael fumes, but Jim holds firm.
你把我们带离主题了。好了。集中注意力，詹娜。总结一下怎么样？在本集中，迈克尔获取了所有人的电子邮件，并发现吉姆正在举办烧烤派对。除了迈克尔，所有人都受到了邀请。迈克尔气急败坏，但吉姆态度坚强。
After attending his weekly improvisation class, Michael crashes the barbecue after all and Pam suspects Dwight and Angela might be a couple. Done, done, done. Yes. This is a big episode. This is a big episode. All right. Fast fact number one.
在参加完每周一次的即兴表演课后，迈克尔还是硬闯了烧烤派对，帕姆怀疑德怀特和安吉拉可能是一对。搞定，搞定，搞定。没错。这是一集重头戏。这是一集重头戏。好的。趣味事实一。
We always start with fast facts, Ken. Well, that's, Jenna loves a fast fact. Okay. Okay. So let's, don't mess with them. No. You like my fast facts. I like them too, but I, it's, it's like you coined the phrase fast fact.
我们总是从趣味事实开始，肯。嗯，那是，詹娜最喜欢趣味事实了。好吧。好吧。所以，别惹它们。不。你喜欢我的趣味事实。我也喜欢，但是，这就像是你创造了“趣味事实”这个短语。
Did I not? Ah. Oh. Did I not? Joe, Michael's flipping you off. Bad Joe. Do our listeners need some context? Bad Joe.
难道不是我吗？啊。哦。难道不是我吗？乔，迈克尔在冲你竖中指。坏乔。我们的听众需要一些背景吗？坏乔。
This is Joe McHale, my nemesis. Okay. So we are, we are in one recording booth and the glass window is facing his. We can see him through the glass and he can see us and he is being offensive. Yes. And aggressive. He gave us the bird and then he mooned us. Joe.
这是乔·麦克海尔，我的死对头。好吧。所以我们，我们在一个录音棚里，玻璃窗正对着他的。我们能透过玻璃看到他，他也能看到我们，他在冒犯我们。没错。而且很有攻击性。他冲我们竖中指，然后还向我们露屁股。乔。
Now he's coming in. Now he's coming in. Lock it. Lock it. I am here with friends. All right. I'm here with people who I love and adore. This is just my favorite Parks and Rec episode.
现在他进来了。现在他进来了。锁上。锁上。我和朋友们在一起。好吧。我和我爱慕的人们在一起。这简直是我最喜欢的《公园与游憩》的一集。
This is, this is the office, Joe. Where Chris cried. No. This is the office. Oh, how dare you. This is the show that started it all and as much as Angela and Jenna are best friends, you and I, if we had a show we would call ourselves community enemies because I didn't like you.
这是，这是《办公室》，乔。克里斯哭的那集。不。这是《办公室》。哦，你怎么敢。这是开创这一切的剧集，尽管安吉拉和詹娜是好朋友，但你和我，如果我们有个节目，我们会称自己为社区死敌，因为我讨厌你。
I never liked you for six seasons. I was over a hundred episodes. We barely tolerated each other and it's, and the antipathy has only grown in the last four years. That is true. And here's the thing. When we saved Ken's career, talking about saving my career, stop it. Have you ever listened?
我连续六季从来没喜欢过你。我拍了一百多集。我们勉强容忍对方，而且这种反感在过去四年里只增不减。千真万确。事情是这样的。当我们拯救了肯的职业生涯时，说什么拯救我的职业生涯，住手。你听过吗？
Stop it. Has he talked about how many? Knock it off. When he's, when you look at his. Knock it off. When you look at his filmography. This. Stop it.
住手。他谈到过多少次？够了。当你看看他的。够了。当你看看他的作品年表。这个。住手。
Hangover. Stop it. Hangover two. How dare you. Hangover three. How about, how about, I'm sorry, but you're leaving furry vengeance. That's a movie. Angela and I did together right before community.
宿醉。住手。宿醉2。你怎么敢。宿醉3。那，那，对不起，你把《毛茸茸的复仇》漏掉了。那是一部电影。我和安吉拉在《废柴联盟》之前一起拍的。
We sat on it. I can't believe you're saying this on Mike. I'm here as a humble day player, talking about how I was bill on email surveillance. I want to go on record and say I really think community enemies is a great podcast. Yeah. I'd be a good companion. That just happened. That just happened.
我们拍了那部。真不敢相信你在麦克风前说这个。我作为一个卑微的仅演一天的特约演员来到这里，谈论我是如何在《电子邮件监控》里演比尔的。我要正式声明，我觉得《社区死敌》真的是个很棒的播客。对。我会是一个很好的搭档。刚才那一幕发生了。刚才那一幕发生了。
Will you please do a rewatch of community with Joel and call it community enemy? And just give each other s**t for like an hour. That is. Speaking of, I'm a really big fan of community and I remembered that we would meet up at all the NBC events because we were on air at the same time and you had such a funny group of people and I loved the show and I would be interested in hearing some behind the scenes banter about that. Yeah.
你能和乔尔一起重温一下《废柴联盟》并把它叫做《社区死敌》吗？然后互相恶心对方一个小时。太棒了。说到这个，我是《废柴联盟》的超级粉丝，我记得我们在所有的NBC活动上都会碰面，因为我们当时同时在播，你们有一群超级有趣的人，我非常喜欢这部剧，我很想听听关于那部剧的一些幕后趣事。对。
No, it was, it was huge because I think the premiere, I think the first two episodes, I think we, we followed the office just to survive on the air on NBC because I mean, the office, you know, Thursday nights at NBC was the flagship show and so when we found out that we would, it would air after the office, we were always, you know, that was, that was like the anchor for us and that it, it's, it's funny how you think certain shows like the office has helped other shows and, and then, you know, get on the air, stay on the air and then give actors like myself and unfortunately Joel, you know, a career and that's been, you know, I'm grateful for mine, you know.
不，这，这非常重要，因为我觉得首播集，我觉得前两集，我觉得我们，我们紧跟在《办公室》后面播出，只是为了能在NBC的荧屏上生存下来，因为我的意思是，《办公室》，你知道的，NBC周四晚上的王牌节目，所以当我们发现它将在《办公室》之后播出时，我们总是，你知道的，那对我们来说就像是一根顶梁柱，而且，这，这很有趣，你以为某些节目比如《办公室》帮助了其他节目，然后，你知道的，登上荧屏，留在荧屏上，然后给像我和不幸的乔尔这样的演员，你知道的，一个职业生涯，而这已经，你知道的，我对我的职业生涯很感激，你知道的。
But the fans should be, um, regretting, Joel, I'm looking at Joel and you can quote me on that. We will. We will. We're gonna, we're gonna use that as our promo clip for this episode. Yes. All right. So before we were so really interrupted, I know before Joel McHale came in and he trashed
但粉丝们应该，嗯，感到后悔，乔尔，我在看着乔尔，你可以引用我的话。我们会。我们会。我们会把这用作这一集的宣传剪辑。是的。好的。所以，在我们被如此打断之前，我知道在乔尔·麦克海尔进来并把我们的桌子
our desk. He literally dumped over a cup of pins. He moved our, he moved our beverages and our tea and I know I was going to discuss my fast facts. Yes. Fast fact number one, this is the first episode from writer Jen Salada. I love Jen Salada. Now she will go on to write fan favorites such as Beach Games and Benny Hanna Christmas
弄得一团糟之前。他 literalmente 把一杯图钉给倒了。他挪动了我们的，他挪动了我们的饮料和茶，我知道我本来要讨论我的趣味事实。是的。趣味事实一，这是编剧简·萨拉塔的第一集。我爱简·萨拉塔。她后来为我们写了许多粉丝最爱的剧集，比如《海滩游戏》和《班尼汉娜的圣诞节》
and many more. She also directed several episodes, but this was her first episode as a writer and we love Jen. One of my favorite memories of Jen, I think more than any other writer is she would giggle behind the monitor and she, her shoulders would shake. It's not that it was easy to make her laugh. It was that she was ready to laugh. She was ready to love what you were doing.
以及更多。她还执导了好几集，但这是她作为编剧的第一集，我们爱简。关于简，我最喜欢的记忆之一，可能超过任何其他编剧，就是她会在监视器后面咯咯笑，然后她的肩膀会颤抖。并不是说逗笑她很容易，而是她随时准备好笑了。她随时准备好去喜爱你正在做的事情。
Mindy was like that too. I have to say, I just loved her energy on set. I think that helps with the actors, right? Like just give the performers a talent or confidence, you know? Yeah. And Jen is the type of person cause she's so earnest and sincere that when she does laugh, it's like her whole body gives into it. It's just, it's just a sweet, wonderful thing to witness.
敏迪也是这样。我必须说，我太喜欢她在片场的那种活力了。我觉得这对演员很有帮助，对吧？就像是给表演者一种天赋或自信，你知道的？是的。简就是那种人，因为她太认真、太真诚了，当她真的笑出来时，仿佛她整个人都融入其中了。那真的是一件很甜蜜、很美好的事情，目睹这一切。
It really is. It really is. All right. Fastback number two. Do it. See? They're fast and they're fast. Oh my God.
真的是这样。真的是这样。好的。趣味事实二。开始吧。看见没？它们不仅快，而且真的很搞笑。天哪。
I'm like Snow like Joe McHale. That's right. All right. We have two big guest stars for this episode. The first is Omivadia who plays the IT specialist Sadiq. Now he is also the star of this Bollywood movie called Three Idiots. It was a huge smash hit. Like he's just gigantic star from this movie.
我就像乔·麦克海尔一样。没错。好的。我们这一集有两个重量级客串明星。第一位是饰演IT专家萨迪克的奥米瓦迪亚。他同时也是那部名为《三傻大闹宝莱坞》的宝莱坞电影的主演。那是一部巨大的轰动之作。就像他因这部电影一跃成为超级巨星一样。
And then he was also in our episode and our other guest star Ken Jong who is in the room with us now. Well, well, Ken, I did not know you when you got the part on the office. We met years later. Right, right. Can you tell us a little bit about how you got the part? I used to be a doctor. I used to be a physician, but I really, I was auditioning just like during like after
然后他也参演了我们这一集，而我们的另一位客串明星肯·郑现在正和我们共处一室。好吧，好吧，肯，你接拍《办公室》的时候我还不认识你。我们是多年后才认识的。对，对。你能跟我们聊聊你是怎么得到这个角色的吗？我以前是个医生。我以前是个内科医生，但我真的，我就是在，比如下班后
work or during lunch and then Allison Jones just took a liking to me and she got me an audition for the office. And it was, keep in mind I really had no screen credits, but she brought me straight into producers. I still remember it vividly. It was an 05 and I had read in front of Jen Salata and Paul Feig, the director of the episode. And I was a huge fan of Paul's from Freaks and Geeks, so I was already just geeking out in the office and I'm not saying it because you're my friends and because this is The Office Ladies.
或者午休期间去试镜，然后艾莉森·琼斯一眼就看中了基调，她为我争取到了《办公室》的试镜机会。记住，我当时真的没有任何影视作品署名，但她直接把我带到了制片人面前。我至今仍记忆犹新。那是05年，我在简·萨拉塔和本集的导演保罗·费格面前读了台词。我是保罗在《怪胎与书呆子》时期的超级粉丝，所以我当时在办公室里简直就像书呆子一样大惊小怪，我这么说不是因为你们是我的朋友，也不是因为这是《办公室女郎》。
It was my favorite show on TV, so and I just a huge BBC office fan, so I just knew the show inside out and so it was really one of the first times, maybe the first time ever I was brought in for a producer's read, you know, with the director in the room. And it's funny now because a lot of people, and rightly so, attribute my acting as very over the top and very, like on community, you know, very, very, just pushing it out. And it's very, you know, very ironic, like really, I think my breakthrough role was playing something very understated and with just maybe two lines and I would basically whisper every line and I improvised a look to camera, even if it wasn't scripted.
这是我电视上最喜欢的节目，所以，而且我是个巨大的BBC版《办公室》粉丝，所以我对这部剧了如指掌，所以这真的是我第一次，也许是有生以来第一次被叫去参加制片人的剧本围读，你知道的，导演就在房间里。现在想起来很有意思，因为很多人，而且理所当然地，认为我的表演非常夸张，非常，就像在《废柴联盟》里一样，你知道的，非常非常，就是把情绪推到极致。而且非常，你知道的，非常具有讽刺意味的是，真的，我认为我的突破性角色反而是扮演一个非常低调的角色，只有两句台词，我基本上每句台词都是用气声说的，我还即兴加了一个对着镜头看的动作，即使剧本里没有写。
And I remember, I still remember where I go, like, he told me he couldn't say, but he has a gun. He looked straight down the barrel and Paul Feig and Jen laughed so hard at this tiny movement. That little choice. That little choice and I still remember, like, Paul could not stop laughing and whenever I see Paul, we still talk about it and it's still, it's one of those things in an actor's life where sometimes, like, I've forgotten years of working on community, probably because
我记得，我依然记得当时的场景，我说，就像，他告诉我他不能说，但他有枪。他直视着枪管，保罗·费格和简被这个微小的动作逗得哈哈大笑。那个小小的选择。那个小小的选择，我至今仍记得，就像，保罗笑得停不下来，每当我见到保罗，我们还会聊起这个，这仍然是演员生涯中那种有时候，就像，我已经忘记了在《废柴联盟》工作的多年时光，可能是
of Joel and, but I remember every single minute of my maybe three hours on the office, you know, it's just really, it's one of those things and I'm sure you have that too in your careers of, you just remember your first time and you just know, if it's not a watershed event, it's maybe your favorite event and that's kind of what, what the office means to me. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Wow.
因为乔尔，但是我还记得我在《办公室》呆的大概三个小时里的每一分每一秒，你知道的，这真的是那种事情，我相信你们在你们的职业生涯中也有过这样的经历，你只记得你的第一次，你知道，如果这算不上一个分水岭式的事件，那它也可能是你最喜欢的事件，这差不多就是，《办公室》对我意味着的一切。是的。哦，我太喜欢这个了。哇。
That's such a wonderful thing to share. I love that, Ken. Thank you. Very grateful. Oh, no. Answering about your time in the scene, Jason P asked, once you started shooting the scenes, how much of the improv was actually improv? That, that's a great question.
这是一个多么美好的分享。我太喜欢了，肯。谢谢。非常感激。噢，不。说到你在片场的那段时光，杰森·P问，一旦你们开始拍摄这些场景，其中有多少即兴表演实际上是即兴的？这，这是个好问题。
To my memory, I remember we shot it a few times as scripted, just so we have it. And then to see Steve Carell and actually, I believe Dee Ryan, who was also in that episode, was a second city, you know, colleague. I knew Dee Ryan from Improv Olympic and had performed with her in the Armando Diaz show. Wow. I knew Dee and Wyatt Snack was in that scene. Wyatt Snack, biggest stars, Joe Nunez, who I've known. And then also Michael Norton, who led the improv scene, who played Chris.
以我的记忆，我记得我们按照剧本拍了几次，只是为了有个底。然后看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，事实上，我相信迪·瑞安，她也参演了那一集，是第二城剧团的，你知道，同事。我从即兴奥林匹克认识迪·瑞安，并曾和她在阿曼多·迪亚兹秀中同台演出。哇。我认识迪，怀亚特·斯拉克也在那个场景里。怀亚特·斯拉克，超级巨星，乔·努涅斯，我认识的。然后还有迈克尔·诺顿，他领导了即兴表演场景，饰演克里斯。
He's a great guy. I had done a sketch comedy show with him, like years ago. Yeah. Yes. Okay, wait, so what, was there improv? After a couple of, I do remember after a couple of things where it was in the script, he was FBI agent Michael Skarnlake, as soon as the end, when we sit down for the postmortem of the scene, Steve goes, I'm sorry, but she was denying me in this whole scene.
他是个大好人。几年前我和他一起做过一个素描喜剧节目。是的。是的。等一下，所以什么，里面有即兴表演吗？在几次之后，我确实记得在剧本里有几个地方，他当时是FBI探员迈克尔·斯卡恩，直到最后，当我们坐下来对这个场景进行事后剖析时，史蒂夫说，我很抱歉，但她在这个整场戏里都在否定我。
She was negating me. This entire scene, and that was not in the script. And they kept arguing back and she goes, you know what, at least I'm not Jim Carrey all this. And he goes, thank you. And they just had this whole back and forth exchange for literally two minutes. And then she storms out of the room, out of the class. And as if it was scripted, as soon as she had her back turned, Michael Skarn had the
她一直在否定我。整场戏都是这样，这根本不在剧本里。然后他们继续争吵，她说，你知道吗，至少我没有像吉姆·凯瑞那样。他说，谢谢你。他们就这样来来回回地争论了足足两分钟。然后她气冲冲地离开房间，走出了课堂。就像是剧本写好的一样，就在她转身的一瞬间，迈克尔·斯卡恩把
gun to the back where it, boom, and I was like, this is like my first big guest star moment or co-star moment. I'm like, I've just never seen this level of genius in my life on a set. It was this improv on top of an improv. And that, that right there, I'll just never forget. So I have another fan question. This is a weird one, but I have to say I noticed as well. Hannah Benson said, I did notice literally everyone in the improv scene has pit stains.
枪对准了背面，砰，我当时想，这简直是我人生中第一个重大的客串明星时刻或联合主演时刻。我想，我从未在片场见过这种水平的天才。这是即兴之上的即兴。而那一幕，我永远都不会忘记。所以我还有一个粉丝的问题。这是一个奇怪的问题，但我必须说我也注意到了。汉娜·b说，我注意到即兴表演场景里的每个人都有腋下汗渍。
Were they not allowed to have air conditioning? Was it real hot? Hot, really hot. I mean, when you guys raise your hands, everyone has a pit stain. He has a huge one when he raises his hands. The women. I know. Even the women who usually sweat less.
他们是不被允许开空调吗？真的很热吗？热，真的很热。我的意思是，当你们举起手时，每个人都有腋下汗渍。当他举起手时，他有一个巨大的汗渍。女性也是。我知道。甚至平时出汗较少的女性也是。
Ken is like laughing so hard. I don't remember. I don't remember any of that. Well guys, you can go back and look at the episode, but when everyone in the improv class raises their hand, it is Sweat City. It is a sweaty day. Hannah Benson and Angela and I all noticed, but you don't have a memory of it being terribly warm in the room.
肯笑得前仰后合。我不记得了。我不记得那些了。好吧，伙计们，你们可以回去看看那一集，但当即兴表演班里的每个人举起手时，那就是汗水之城。那是汗流浃背的一天。汉娜·b、安吉拉和我都注意到了，但你对房间里热得可怕这件事一点记忆都没有吗？
No, we shot that in, we shot that in the fall and I just remember it was cold. It was, I just remember it was cold. I had to wear, actually the wardrobe that I had on the show, that was my own clothes. I believe that. Yeah. I wore my own clothes in the pilot. Really? Wow.
没有，我们是在，我们是在秋天拍摄的，我只记得当时很冷。当时是，我只记得很冷。我不得不穿，实际上我在剧里穿的服装，那是我的私服。我相信这个。对。我在试播集里穿的是我自己的衣服。真的吗？哇。
I had a two string budget at this time. Yeah. I had my own, I had a ski jacket on. That was my own jacket that I wore to set. I mean, everyone, I was such a green horn, just not knowing anything. I had even gelled my own, like I just. You did your own hair. You came ready.
我当时只有两根弦的预算。对。我有我自己的，我穿着一件滑雪夹克。那是我的夹克，我穿着它去了片场。我的意思是，每个人，我当时是个十足的新手，什么都不懂。我甚至自己抹了发胶，就像我只是。你自己弄的头发。你准备好了才来的。
I came ready. Shown up dressed and ready to shoot. I came ready like Tootsie, you know? It was like, I had everything ready, like it was, I was so green. I was so green. I had no idea. What was it like doing that scene with Steve? To this day, it's just something I'll never forget because he was coming out the 40 year
我准备好了才来的。打扮好并准备好拍摄。我像《窈窕淑男》那样准备好了，你知道吗？就像是，我把一切都准备好了，就像是，我太青涩了。我太青涩了。我完全不知道。和史蒂夫演那场戏是什么感觉？直到今天，那依然是我永远不会忘记的事情，因为他刚刚拍完《40岁的老处男》，而我前一个月才刚刚在电影院里看他的电影
old virgin and I'd literally just watched him in the movie theater, you know, the previous month and it, you know, so I'm sharing a scene with the biggest star in comedy. You know, he really is a role model to me because he is, he really is just a professional, elegant, classy actor who has, he has no weakness in his game and, you know, either on or off screen. So he's just someone that I just really look up to. That was so beautifully said. No, it really was.
，你知道的，所以我和喜剧界最大的巨星分享了一场戏。你知道，他真的是我的榜样，因为他真的只是一个专业、优雅、有品位的演员，他在他的游戏里没有任何弱点，你知道的，无论是银幕内还是银幕外。所以他真的是我非常仰慕的人。这话说得太美妙了。不，真的。
I mean, he is a role, he's a role model to me too because it kind of what you're talking about, like you now in life, you are Steve Carell to other young actors who get paired with you. And I always remember, I look back on how Steve treated people and I think that's how I want to be. If I'm ever in a position where I'm the Steve Carell of a moment, like not Steve Carell, but within a moment, I want to behave like he did. I want to be generous and thoughtful and giving and warm and inviting of this actor who's
我的意思是，他也是我的榜样，因为这有点像你刚才说的，你现在的生活中，对于其他和你搭档的年轻演员来说，你就是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我总是回想起史蒂夫对待别人的方式，我想那就是我想成为的样子。如果我有一天处于这样一个位置，我是那一刻的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，虽然不是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，但在那种情况下，我想像他那样行事。我想慷慨、体贴、给予、热情，并欢迎这位对这个体系完全陌生
brand new to the system. Yeah, I remember, I remember talking to him, I had a short lipstick on ABC for a couple years that I created and wrote and I asked, I had run into Steve somewhere and I had asked him for advice and he actually, he had said, you know, you can't go wrong with just leading by example, just, hey, if you're not going to act difficult and nobody's going to act difficult. I remember he told me that and it was, yeah, and I remember thinking about that when, like he said, I had my, I had a moment and I remember thinking to myself, if I work hard, everyone
的新演员。是的，我记得，我记得和他谈过，我在ABC有一部我创作和编剧的短命情景喜剧，持续了几年，我曾在某处偶遇史蒂夫，我向他讨教过建议，他实际上说过，你知道的，以身作则永远不会错，就像，嘿，如果你不表现得难以相处，没有人会表现得难以相处。我记得他跟我说过这个，而且，是的，当我经历过那种时刻时，我总是会想起这句话，我记得当时心里想，如果我努力工作，每个人
else will work hard. Ken, thank you so much. Are you kidding? Thank you for having me. For coming in. I really thank you. Cheers to you guys. Congrats on this.
都会努力工作。肯，非常感谢你。开玩笑吗？谢谢你们邀请我。能来我真的非常感谢。向你们致敬。恭喜你们。
So generous of you to give us your time. The office was my favorite guest star appearance ever and it's just, it really just helped jumpstart my career. So thank you. Well, listen, we were not on community, neither of us, but when you and Joel do community ceremonies, we will come on, you guys, we'll just come in and you'll be, you'll be giving us notes. We'll storm your room.
你太慷慨了，把时间分给我们。《办公室》是我最喜欢的客串出演，它真的帮我开启了职业生涯。所以谢谢你们。好吧，听着，我们没有演过《废柴联盟》，我们俩都没有，但当你在乔尔的《社区典礼》上时，我们会来的，伙计们，我们会直接走进来，然后你们会，你们会给我们提意见。我们会冲进你的房间。
Yeah. You'll store in the room, give us notes. Hey, maybe, maybe a little bit of friendship could show up in this episode. I'm just going to come in and flip off Joel and dump his pins on his lap. Done. We're, we're the anti-office. This is all class, fun, dignity, and then me and Joel are just like, you get your, your intro can be, you know, we're going to give each week, we're going to watch an episode
对。你们会冲进房间，给我们提意见。嘿，也许，也许这个节目里能展现一点友谊。我正要走进去，冲乔尔竖中指，把他的图钉倒在他的大腿上。搞定。我们是反办公室。这里全是优雅、趣味、尊严，然后我和乔尔就像是，你的开场白可以是，你知道的，我们每周都会看一集
of community and we're going to give you all the behind the scenes info and trivia that only two people who hate one another can tell you and really tell you all the fights, all of the, and do a deep dive, all of the tension, do a deep dive critiquing each other's performance and performance and lot in life, and like personal, personal, personal choices, not just professional, yeah, physical attacks, I know. All right, Kim, thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you guys.
《废柴联盟》，然后我们会为你提供所有的幕后信息和琐事，只有两个互相讨厌的人才能告诉你，并且真正地告诉你所有的争吵，所有的，进行深入剖析，批评彼此的表演和表现以及生活际遇，就像是私人的、私人的、私人的选择，不仅仅是专业的，是的，身体攻击，我懂。好了，肯，非常谢谢你。谢谢。谢谢你们。
We're going to take a break and then we'll be back to break down the rest of this episode. Okay, we're back. We are back. Thank you, Ken Jong. And not thank you, Joel McHale. Not thank you, Joel McHale. If you're tracking, and maybe you are, I hope you are, that we did not do our third fast fact.
我们要休息一下，然后回来剖析这一集的剩余部分。好了，我们回来了。我们回来了。谢谢肯·郑。不用谢乔尔·麦克海尔。不用谢乔尔·麦克海尔。如果你一直在关注，也许你在关注，我希望你在关注，我们刚才没有做我们的第三个趣味事实。
We did not. And it's a special fast fact. It's special because Angela and I both found our journals. We found our journals that we wrote in after each episode, sometimes during an episode. Yeah. You guys, I have journaled for so long, I have, I found like in setting up my she-shed, 12 journals. Oh my gosh.
我们确实没做。这是一个特殊的趣味事实。之所以特殊，是因为安吉拉和我都找到了我们的日记。我们找到了我们在每集之后写的日记，有时甚至在拍摄某集期间写的。是的。你们知道吗，我写日记写了太久了，我在整理我的“女性专属小屋”时，找到了12本日记。噢，天哪。
Angela. I had so much to say. I've been journaling since I could write. I mean, I have journals about my crushes in second grade. I found a journal from college that is like, I'm like, who is this person? I'll tell you what, she was real hung up on a certain fella for a while. In this journal entry, I wrote about this exact episode of the office. Here's what I wrote.
安吉拉。我有那么多话要说。我从会写字开始就一直在写日记。我的意思是，我有关于我在二年级时的暗恋对象的日记。我找到了一本大学时的日记，上面写着，我在想，这人是谁啊？我告诉你吧，她当时对某个家伙真的是迷恋了好一阵子。在这篇日记里，我写到了《办公室》这一集。这是我写的。
Here's a gem. It rained for three days while we were shooting this episode. It takes five days to shoot an episode. And for three of the five days, it rained like downpour heavy rains, apparently. No rain. I noted that our AD Richard had to wear a parka. He's the person who would knock on our trailer doors and get us to come from our trailers across the parking lot onto the stages.
这里有个宝贝。我们在拍这一集的时候连着下了三天雨。拍一集需要五天时间。在这五天里有三天雨下得像倾盆大雨一样大，显然。没有雨。我注意到我们的副导演理查德不得不穿一件派克大牌。就是那个会敲我们的拖车门，叫我们从拖车穿过停车场来到舞台的人。
It was a little bit of a walk, you guys, and this parking lot would flood. There'd be huge puddles of water. And I guess it really caused a problem for hair, makeup, and wardrobe because we would get ready outside in our trailers. And then by the time we got to set, we were drenched. And I wrote all about it in my journal. I said that we had umbrellas. We each got an umbrella with our name on it.
那可真有一段路程，伙计们，而且这个停车场会淹水。会有巨大的水坑。我想这确实给发型、化妆和服装部门造成了麻烦，因为我们是在外面的拖车里做好准备的。然后等我们走到片场时，我们已经湿透了。我把这些全写进日记里了。我说我们有雨伞。我们每人发了一把写有我们名字的伞。
Remember that? Yeah. They would give her a little sticker so that we could keep track. I have to share with you that I often would misplace my umbrella and I would just take someone else's Angela. And then I would hear Richard on the radio being like, has anyone seen John's umbrella? Anyone? I'd be like, eh, it might be in my trailer.
还记得吗？对。他们会给它贴个小贴纸，这样我们就能追踪了。我必须告诉你们，我经常会放错我的雨伞，然后我就会拿走安吉拉的伞。然后我就会听到理查德在对讲机里喊，有人看到琼的伞了吗？有人吗？我会说，呃，可能在我的拖车里。
I also noted, speaking of John, that John's birthday was the week that we shot this episode. He turned 26. 26? Yeah. Oh my Lord, that's so young. I know. He and BJ and Mindy were all the youngsters because the rest of us were all in our 30s and beyond, but they were still in their 20s.
我还注意到，说到琼，琼的生日正好是我们拍摄这一集的那个星期。他26岁了。26岁？对。噢，天哪，太年轻了。我知道。他和B.J.还有敏迪都是年轻人，因为我们其余的人都三十岁及以上了，但他们还在二十多岁。
Wowzers. Okay, so I also wrote my journal. Now I wrote about some things that happen at Jim's party and a few other places in the episode. I'm going to save those, Jenna. Okay. I'm going to give one thing I wrote about. Jenna, we carpooled to work this week.
哇塞。好了，所以我也写了我的日记。现在我写了一些发生在吉姆派对上的事情以及这一集里的其他几个地方。我要把那些留着，詹娜。好的。我要分享我写的一件事。詹娜，我们这周是拼车去上班的。
When we were shooting this episode? Yes. I wrote that we had to go on location. We were very excited because Jim's party, his barbecue, happened at his apartment and we got to drive to location. And I wrote that you and I carpooled and we had the best time. I wrote, I was like, we chatted, we sang songs and you know, we solved the world's problems. That's what I wrote.
我们在拍这一集的时候？对。我写到我们要去外景地。我们非常兴奋，因为吉姆的派对，他的烧烤派对，是在他的公寓里举办的，我们得开车去外景地。我写道，你和我拼车了，我们玩得超级开心。我写道，我当时想，我们聊天，我们唱歌，你知道的，我们解决了世界上的问题。这就是我写的。
I do not remember that. I don't remember it either, but we clearly had a great time. I love that you wrote that down because I'm sure we did do that because we lived really close. We lived really close and we were probably so excited that we had to commute. Yeah. We had to drive far. And I said it was a little bit of a drive, but the thing that really cracked me up is
我不记得了。我也不记得了，但我们显然度过了一段美好的时光。我很高兴你把它写了下来，因为我相信我们确实这么做了，因为我们住得很近。我们住得很近，我们可能太兴奋了，因为我们需要通勤。是的。我们得开车开很远。我说路程有点远，但真正让我忍俊不禁的是
I said, we sang our hearts out and we solved the world's problems. We probably did. What did we sing, Jenna? What did we sing? I'd love to know. I wish I knew. Sounds of Scranton. Well, I hope we sang Sounds of Scranton.
我说，我们尽情歌唱，我们解决了世界上的问题。我们可能真的这么做了。我们唱了什么，詹娜？我们唱了什么？我很想知道。我希望我知道。斯克兰顿之声。好吧，我希望我们唱的是斯克兰顿之声。
All right. So let's get into this episode now. We're going to start breaking it down. It starts with the cold open. Yes. So Sadiq is coming to fix an IT problem, right? And Michael looks out his window. He sees him coming.
好了，让我们进入这一集吧。我们要开始剖析它了。它以冷开场开始。是的。所以萨迪克来修复一个IT问题，对吧？迈克尔看着他的窗外。他看到他走过来。
He panics because probably Michael has some growing in maturity to do about how he perceives others. That's how I'm going to say it. That's a good way to put it. He has some maturing to do. So anyway, he freaks out. He wants to turn off the lights and have everyone hide, but do you remember how we couldn't get it coordinated, Jenna?
他恐慌了，因为可能迈克尔在如何看待他人方面还有些不成熟的地方需要成长。我打算这么说。这是个委婉的说法。他还有些不成熟的地方需要成长。总之，他吓坏了。他想关掉灯，让大家都藏起来，但你还记得我们当时怎么都无法协调好吗，詹娜？
We couldn't turn off the lights at the right time. Yes. People should know that in the scene when Michael runs over to shut off the light switches, those light switches do not actually operate the lights. The lights are controlled by a grid and a guy. He has in charge of them. And so what they would do is they would have someone on a radio who would see when Steve hit the light switch and then they would radio go.
我们无法在正确的时间关掉灯。是的。人们应该知道，在迈克尔跑过去关闭电灯开关的那场戏里，那些电灯开关实际上并不能控制灯光。灯光是由一个网格和一个专人来控制的。他负责这些。所以他们会做的是，他们会让一个人拿着对讲机，看着史蒂夫按下电灯开关，然后他们就会在对讲机里喊走。
And then the light switch guy would actually turn off the lights. But it didn't always work. So sometimes Steve would hit the switch and the lights would just stay on, or sometimes they would anticipate too quickly and the lights would go off before he hit the switch. Again, this is one of those moments when like, thank God we didn't have to do any car chases or explosions. It's so true. It seems like the light switch was like really tricky for us.
然后控制灯光的人才会真正关掉灯。但这并不总是管用。所以有时史蒂夫按下开关，灯依然亮着，或者有时他们预判得太快，在史蒂夫按下开关之前灯就灭了。同样，这也是那种“谢天谢地我们不需要拍任何汽车追逐或爆炸戏”的时刻。太真实了。看起来电灯开关对我们来说真的很棘手。
I have to ask you one thing. Okay. So Sadiq from IT is coming to help Michael, right? I just have to say this, Jenna, at one minute, 26 seconds, this actually like, I thought about this for days after watching this episode. Michael says he tried to install the software himself, but it was password protected. Sadiq says, that just means you have to enter your password. Does this mean that Sadiq didn't?
我必须问你一件事。好吧。所以来自IT的萨迪克来帮迈克尔，对吧？我必须说这个，詹娜，在一分钟26秒时，这实际上，我在看完这一集的好几天里都一直在想这件事。迈克尔说他试图自己安装软件，但有密码保护。萨迪克说，那只是意味着你必须输入你的密码。这是否意味着萨迪克根本不需要？
He didn't even have to come there? If Michael had just entered one, two, three, four, that was on the post-it note, had he just entered that? The software would have installed. I think that's what that means. So that is so like, if you put that in perspective, Sadiq is probably like this idiot. All he had to do was enter the password. I put on a post-it note and taped to his desktop.
他甚至都不用亲自跑来？如果迈克尔只是输入了贴在便签上的1、2、3、4，如果他只是输入了那个？软件就会安装好了。我想这就是那个意思。所以这太，如果你从这个角度来看，萨迪克大概会觉得这个笨蛋真蠢。他所需要做的就是输入密码。我把它写在便签上并贴在他的台式机上了。
It also feels like something that could have been solved with a phone call. Yes. He definitely did not need to come into the office and be subjected to Michael's cold open. No, no. Oh my gosh. So, at one minute, 46 seconds, Dwight surprises Michael outside of his office, right? He's demanding to know why the IT guy is there, and of course, Michael doesn't want to tell
这也感觉像是一通电话就能解决的事情。是的。他绝对不需要来到办公室，并遭受迈克尔冷开场的折磨。不，不。噢，天哪。所以，在一分钟46秒时，德怀特在办公室外面给了迈克尔一个惊吓，对吧？他质问为什么IT人员在那里，当然，迈克尔不想告诉
him because it's going to be revealed that he's there to install software so that Michael can spy on everybody's emails. Well, I want you to look in the background of this scene, as Steve's coming out the door, he quickly shuts the door behind him. That's because Omi was not there on that day of filming. So he had to quickly shut the door. Yeah, Steve has to shimmy out and then shut the door behind him so that you won't see that the office is actually empty.
他，因为这会暴露他是来安装软件的，好让迈克尔监视每个人的电子邮件。好吧，我想让你看看这个场景的背景，当史蒂夫走出门时，他迅速把身后的门关上了。那是因为奥米在那天拍摄时并不在场。所以他不得不迅速把门关上。是的，史蒂夫不得不扭动着身子出来，然后把身后的门关上，这样你就不会看到办公室其实是空的。
Oh, look at you with your little behind the scenes nugget. Yes. All right. At two minutes, 14 seconds, Dwight lists off what could possibly happen to Michael so that he might take over the office. Yeah. Right? Yeah.
哦，看看你，带着你的幕后小干货。是的。好的。在两分钟14秒时，德怀特列举了迈克尔可能发生的不测，以便他可以接管办公室。对吧？是的。
Here are the things that could happen. Okay. Number one, brain aneurysm. Oh. Number two, getting hit by a car, a bus, or a train. Number three, poisoned, fall down a well, step on a mine. These are like Dwight has thought this out, you guys. This is what could happen, and he'd have to do an immediate takeover.
以下是可能发生的事情。好吧。第一，脑动脉瘤。哦。第二，被汽车、公共汽车或火车撞到。第三，中毒、掉进水井、踩到地雷。这些就像是德怀特已经想得很周全了，伙计们。这就是可能发生的事情，而他不得不立即接管。
Immediate takeover. And Michael has that great line where he says, you know what, Dwight, if I step on a mine in Scranton, Pennsylvania, you can have my job. So annoyed. Yeah. So the next big scene is kind of in the bullpen when Oscar confronts Michael about spying on everyone's emails. He does it in front of everyone.
立即接管。迈克尔有一句很棒的台词，他说，你知道吗，德怀特，如果我在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿踩到地雷，你可以得到我的工作。超级恼火。是的。所以接下来的重头戏有点像在开放式办公区，奥斯卡就监视大家电子邮件的事质问迈克尔。他当着所有人的面这么做了。
I loved it whenever Oscar confronted Michael in front of everyone, and he does this throughout the series, and it's just some of my favorite moments of the show. He is able to take Michael to task like no one else. I think Stanley also does this from time to time, but Stanley is usually more under his breath. I think he's a little more to the side about it. In this scene, Steve does this never-ending robot bit. Oscar's trying to get a word out, and Steve just keeps doing the robot thing.
每当奥斯卡当着所有人的面质问迈克尔时，我都超级喜欢，而且他在整部剧中都一直在这么做，这简直是我对这部剧最喜欢的时刻之一。他能够像其他人一样狠狠地数落迈克尔。我想斯坦利有时也会这样做，但斯坦利通常说话更含蓄一点。我觉得他对此稍微更边缘一些。在这场戏里，史蒂夫做了一个没完没了的机器人动作。奥斯卡试图插话，而史蒂夫却一直在做机器人动作。
I remember shooting that. So in the script, that was not supposed to go on for that long. That was supposed to just be like a quick little thing, but Steve really dragged it out, and that was an example, I think, of some of his just brilliant comedic timing. I honestly think that Steve would drag things out like that to see when he could get all of us to break. And we would break. He did break in that.
我记得当时拍摄的情景。所以在剧本里，那本不应该持续那么长时间的。那本应该只是一个小插曲，但史蒂夫真的把它拉得很长，我认为这就是他那精湛的喜剧时机的一个例子。我老实说，史蒂夫会把事情拖延成这样，是为了看看什么时候能让我们所有人都笑场。而我们确实笑场了。他确实在那个场景里笑场了。
He was a little sadistic that way. He'd be like, oh, you haven't broken yet? How about this? Yeah. How about this? Kinsey, I see you going. Just keep going until we fell apart. Well, right after this, then, we have the little aside.
他那方面有点虐待狂倾向。他会觉得，哦，你们还没笑场吗？这个怎么样？是的。这个怎么样？金西，我看到你在笑了。直到我们崩溃之前一直继续。好吧，就在这之后，然后，我们有了小插曲。
Well, the erasing begins, right? The erasing begins. And Dwight says to Angela, if you have any sensitive emails, they need to be deleted immediately. Pam over here, she calls Jim over. She suspects that they might be a couple. This is the first moment where we call out that Dwight and Angela might be together. Well, the first moment that anyone in the office has any idea, right?
好吧，开始删除了，对吧？开始删除了。德怀特对安吉拉说，如果你有任何敏感的电子邮件，必须立即删除。帕姆这边，她把吉姆叫了过去。她怀疑他们可能是一对。这是我们第一次指出德怀特和安吉拉可能在一起。好吧，也是办公室里的任何人有此察觉的第一次，对吧？
Yes. Yeah. So the question from Kelsey McGrath, Angela, when did Angela and Rain find out that they were love interests? I mean, I'm not sure if Rain had any heads up before I did, but I found out at the table read. Really? Yeah.
是的。是的。所以凯尔西·麦格拉斯的问题，安吉拉，安吉拉和雷恩是什么时候发现他们是一对恋人的？我的意思是，我不太确定雷恩是否比我先得到任何风声，但我是在剧本围读时发现的。真的吗？是的。
When we sat down to read the script and Oscar. So no one warned you beforehand? No one warned me beforehand. I had no idea. And when we sat down at the table read and we read that their Birkenstocks were bumping, right? I was like, huh, well, I remember there was an audible gasp in the room when we read that there were times when we would do these table reads where people would be legitimately surprised
当我们坐下来读剧本和奥斯卡时。所以之前没有人警告你吗？之前没有人警告我。我完全不知道。当我们坐在围读桌旁，读到他们的勃肯鞋（Birkenstocks）在碰撞，对吧？我就想，呃，我记得当我们在读到这些时，房间里发出了一声惊呼，有时候我们在进行这些围读时，人们会真的感到惊讶
by plot twists. And this was definitely one of them. This one we found out Oscar was gay. Yes. Right? Yes. I mean, when we found out Jim and Pam were going to have a baby. Yes.
被情节反转惊到。而这绝对是其中之一。这一集我们发现奥斯卡是同性恋。是的。对吧？是的。我的意思是，当我们发现吉姆和帕姆要有一个孩子时。是的。
I mean, there were these big moments, but I did not know. And I remember being like, oh my God. And I definitely don't think a lot of the cast members knew because there were there were real reactions there. Yes. I also, I know we're going back a little bit, but I love that Kevin says he has to delete a lot. A lot.
我是说，这些都是重大的时刻，但我当时并不知道。我记得当时我的反应是，哦，天哪。而且我绝对认为很多演员都不知道，因为当时大家的反应都是真实的。是的。还有，我知道我们有点倒回去了，但我太喜欢凯文说他必须删掉很多东西了。很多。
Gross, Kevin. What's going on over there? Pam has a talking head next. Oh, wait. Can I say one thing? Yeah. Jenna, just to go back to Jim and Pam's conversation about Dwight and Angela. Yeah.
真恶心，凯文。那边在搞什么鬼？接下来是帕姆的单人采访。哦，等等。我能说一件事吗？可以。珍娜，回到吉姆和帕姆关于德怀特和安吉拉的对话。对。
This happens at four minutes, 45 seconds. I want you guys to rewatch the scene. Pam is so grossed out. And so is Jim at the idea of Dwight and Angela. They're like, I'm just like, come on, what's wrong with that? Two people falling in love. Pam is like, I can't. We are a little over the top about it.
这发生在4分45秒。我想让你们重新看一下这个场景。帕姆对德怀特和安吉拉的想法感到非常恶心。吉姆也是。他们觉得，我就想，拜托，这有什么不好的？两个人坠入爱河。帕姆却说，我受不了。我们在这事儿上确实有点反应过度。
You're so grossed out by it. I was like, geez. Well, Pam then goes and has a talking head where she says directly to the documentary film crew, if you see anything, let me know. Oh, yeah. She's like all chummy with the documentary crew. She full on invites them to help. I think this is the first time we see this moment where someone in the show speaks directly
你对这事儿太恶心了。我都觉得，天哪。好吧，帕姆随后接了一个单人采访，她在采访中直接对纪录片摄制组说，如果你们看到什么，请告诉我。哦，是的。她和纪录片摄制组好得像哥们儿一样。她完全是在邀请他们来帮忙。我想这是我们第一次看到剧中有角色直接
to the character of the documentarian. Right. Who we never see. Right. But yeah. I think that Pam and Jim probably are the two people that engage with them the most. I mean, Michael, because he's a showboat, you know, but it's like Pam knows them. That's what it felt like in that moment.
对纪录片制作人角色说话的时刻。对。我们从未见过的人。对。但是，是的。我觉得帕姆和吉姆可能是跟他们互动最多的两个人。我是说，迈克尔也有，因为爱出风头嘛，你知道的，但帕姆是真正了解他们。那一刻给人的感觉就是这样。
Yeah. Like they're kind of friends or something. Yeah. All right. So something else in Pam's talking head at four minutes, 57 seconds. I'm tracking the mail cart now. She is, you guys. She's become obsessed with the mail cart.
对。就像他们是某种朋友或者别的什么。对。好吧。所以帕姆在4分57秒的单人采访中还有别的内容。我现在在追踪邮件车。各位，她真的在追踪。她已经对邮件车着迷了。
I'm tracking Casual Fridays and the mail cart. And I want you all to know that Meredith comes over to the mail cart behind me during my talking head. Thank you. I'm applauding. I'm applauding Jonah's mail cart tracking. The mail cart got used. And then at five minutes, 12 seconds, there's just this interaction between Pam and Dwight
我在追踪便装星期五（Casual Fridays）和邮件车。我想让大家知道，在我接受单人采访时，梅雷迪思走到了我身后的邮件车旁。谢谢。我在鼓掌。我为乔纳对邮件车的追踪鼓掌。邮件车被用上了。然后在大约5分12秒，帕姆和德怀特之间有这样一段互动
that I love. I actually love Pam and Dwight scenes. They're some of my favorite. Yeah. You are often so like just exasperated by him. And it's one of my favorite things you do is Pam. She comes up to him. Pam's on the case.
我非常喜欢。其实我很喜欢帕姆和德怀特的对手戏。那是我最喜欢的片段之一。对。你通常对他是那么地……感到气恼。这是你演帕姆时我最喜欢的特质之一。她朝他走过去。帕姆开始调查了。
She's very excited, detective Pam. She's like Dwight. So my friend is kind of, you know, into these two girls and Dwight's like, nice. And your face is like, oh, good. At five minutes, 41 seconds, we find out that Dwight, as a volunteer sheriff, goes through everyone's medical records. So that's great. Gross.
她非常兴奋，侦探帕姆。她说，德怀特，我的一个朋友呢，有点，你知道的，对这两个女孩挺感兴趣。德怀特说，不错。而你的表情就像是，哦，好吧。在5分41秒，我们发现德怀特作为志愿警长，会去翻查所有人的医疗记录。所以这太棒了。真恶心。
Gross, Dwight. My gosh. All right, Jenna, I have a thing that I track, you know, it's called old tech. Oh yeah. What's your old tech track? Guys, I think we should just call this the We Tracked it episode. We tracked it. We're on the case.
真恶心，德怀特。我的天啊。好吧，珍娜，我有一个我追踪的东西，你知道的，叫做老旧科技。哦，是的。你追踪的老旧科技是什么？伙计们，我觉得我们应该直接把这一集叫做“我们追踪了”单集。我们追踪了。我们在调查了。
We're on the case. Much like Pam, we're on the case. I love me some old tech and at five minutes, 57 seconds, you see the evite and you see it's like so outdated looking. If you go to evite now, it's like, it looks like the old evites of that day and age, if you will. Yes. This is the scene where Michael is discovering the evite and he learns that Jim is having
我们在调查了。就像帕姆一样，我们在调查。我特别喜欢一些老旧科技，在5分57秒，你看到了Evite电子请柬，你看它看起来太老气了。如果你现在去看Evite，它就像是……它看起来就像那个年代的老式Evite，如果你愿意这么说的话。是的。这就是迈克尔发现这个Evite并得知吉姆在家里办烧烤派对
a barbecue at his house and he is not invited. He's not invited. He sees the list of people who are invited and he is sort of looking around. He's using his mouse, right? Yeah. And it all is so old looking, super old graphic. So next, Detective Pam walks up to Angela at the vending machine. Oh, you guys, this is like some of my favorite stuff.
而他没有被邀请的场景。他没有被邀请。他看到了受邀人员名单，然后他环顾四周。他在用鼠标，对吧？是的。这一切看起来都太旧了，超级老旧的图形界面。接下来，侦探帕姆走向自动售货机旁的安吉拉。哦，伙计们，这绝对是我最喜欢的内容之一。
I also wrote about this in my journal. I wrote, you guys, Jenna and I have a scene together. We're so excited. We did get so excited when we had scenes together. We were horrible because then we would just laugh and be idiots once we were in the scene. And they would take forever and people would get like really tired of us. It's true. But we were really excited about this scene.
我还在日记里写了这件事。我写道，伙计们，珍娜和我有一场对手戏。我们太兴奋了。我们一起拍对手戏时确实会超级兴奋。我们当时表现得太糟糕了，因为一旦进入场景，我们就会一直笑，像个傻子一样。这会花很长时间，大家都会对我们感到非常厌烦。确实。但我们对这场戏真的很兴奋。
We were. I ask Angela if she's bringing anyone to the party and Angela says no. But then Angela buys an extra candy bar. Yeah. Two baby Ruth bars. Evidence. Dun, dun, dun. Fan question.
我们确实很兴奋。我问安吉拉是否要带人去派对，安吉拉说不。但接着安吉拉买了一根额外的糖果棒。是的。两根贝比露丝（Baby Ruth）糖果棒。证据。当、当、当。粉丝提问。
Michael and Kristen Mulligan want to know why did you choose baby Ruth for you and Dwight? Did you, Angela, the person get to choose what the candy would be or was it scripted? Probably Phil Shea or Prop Sky would give us a few options and there were options that had been cleared because for legal reasons you have to make sure you can use logos and things like that. So they probably gave us a few options. I actually love baby Ruth bars. So I guess I want, I'm sure I was like, ooh, baby Ruth bar.
迈克尔和克里斯汀·马利根想知道，你为什么为你和德怀特选择贝比露丝？安吉拉，作为本人的你，是有机会选择什么糖果，还是剧本里写好的？可能是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）或者道具组（Prop Sky）给我们提供了几个选项，这些选项都是经过清除的，因为出于法律原因，你必须确保你可以使用徽标和类似的东西。所以他们可能给了我们几个选项。其实我很喜欢贝比露丝糖果棒。所以我猜我当时肯定说过，哦，贝比露丝糖果棒。
And thank goodness, I guess Frayne agreed because he had to eat one too. No kidding. Yeah. So I think that's probably how it went down. I want to point out though, you guys, one of the things I love in this scene is that as Pam goes to pick something from the vending machine, I swat her hand away and I'm like, excuse me. I love it whenever my character would just swat someone away.
谢天谢地，我猜弗雷恩也同意了，因为他也得吃一根。开玩笑吧。是的。所以我想事情大概就是这样发展的。不过我想指出的是，伙计们，这场戏里我最喜欢的一个细节是，当帕姆伸手去自动售货机拿东西时，我把她的手拍开，然后说，不好意思。每当我能用角色一把把别人拍开时，我都超级喜欢。
It's so dismissive. It just made me laugh. Pam was probably going to buy some of her chips. Her gross smelly chips. Okay. Also, Angela, in this scene at six minutes, 47 seconds, there is a really great shot as you're bending down to get the snacks of your ponytail. I know it sounded like I was going to say something else.
这种态度太不屑一顾了。这简直让我笑死。帕姆当时可能想买点她的薯片。她那恶心、气味难闻的薯片。好的。还有，安吉拉，在这场戏6分47秒的时候，当你弯腰去拿零食时，有一个非常棒的镜头拍到了你的马尾辫。我知道听起来我好像要说别的什么。
It's your ponytail. There's a great shot of your ponytail. It's a family show, lady. I know. Yes. You've got hair wrapped around my own hair. Yeah, describe it. Okay.
是你的马尾辫。有一个关于你的马尾辫的绝佳镜头。这是一部合家欢剧集，女士。我知道。是的。你有一缕头发缠绕在你自己的头发上。对，描述一下。好的。
This is a classic Kim Ferry thing where even the ponytails were amazing. She would pull my hair back in this sort of severe ponytail, but then she would leave a big chunk of it out and she would wrap it around the ponytail holder so it looks like my own hair is holding up the ponytail. It's very polished looking. I know. And it's very Angela Martin to do this. It's very detail.
这是典型的金·费里（Kim Ferry）风格，连马尾辫都弄得惊艳无比。她会把我的头发扎成这种一丝不苟的马尾辫，但她会留出一大束头发，然后把它缠绕在发圈上，这样看起来就像是我自己的头发在固定着马尾辫。看起来非常精致。我知道。这非常符合安吉拉·马丁的作风。细节满满。
Very Angela Martin to do it, but I used to joke with Kim. I would be like, how early does Angela get up to do these elaborate braids and also, is she an octopus? How does she get back there? How many, does she have like a mirror behind her head? What does her bathroom look like? How does she do this? I have done that ponytail to myself because I thought it was so genius.
非常符合安吉拉·马丁的风格，但我以前经常跟金开玩笑。我会问，安吉拉到底起得有多早才能梳出这么复杂的编发，还有，她是一只八爪鱼吗？她是怎么够到脑后的？她有多少……她的脑后是不是长了面具？她的浴室到底长什么样？她是怎么做到的？我自己也给自己梳过那个马尾辫，因为我觉得这太天才了。
It is not that difficult to pull off. Really? It looks really good. Well, I am crap with my own hair, so you might have to give me a tutorial. Well guys, you should check it out if you're looking to spruce up your ponytail. Six minutes, 47 seconds. Fancy pony. Fancy pony.
其实梳起来并没有那么难。真的吗？看起来真的很不错。好吧，我对自己的头发简直手残，所以你可能得教教我。好吧，伙计们，如果你想让你的马尾辫看起来更精神，真该去看看这个。6分47秒。精致的马尾。精致的马尾。
Great ponytail. Well, you know the scene in the kitchen where Steve, as Michael, is eating a cup of noodles and he's confronting the group. He's trying to get us to feel guilty and or invite him to this party that he's not been invited to. John and I had a massive, massive laughing fit during this lunch scene. So much so, you can see I'm eating some yogurt, so much so that I snorted the yogurt up into my nose, which is probably painful.
超棒的马尾辫。好吧，你知道厨房里的那个场景，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔正在吃一杯杯面，他在质问大家。他试图让我们感到内疚，或者邀请他参加这个他没有被邀请的派对。我和约翰在这个午餐场景中笑得简直昏天黑地、一塌糊涂。以至于你可以看到我正在吃酸奶，我甚至把酸奶从鼻子里喷出来了，这可能挺疼的。
It was a little burny, which then caused John to laugh so hard that he was crying. And it was just the two of us. The two of us were having a moment where we could not get it together. You couldn't get it back. We couldn't. I don't know how they had any usable takes. I want you to know I went and watched the season two bloopers. Okay.
当时有点刺鼻，这随后又导致约翰笑得眼泪都流出来了。当时就只有我们俩。我们俩当时的状态就是完全没办法把戏演下去。你们根本收不住。我们收不住。我都不知道他们是怎么剪出能用的镜头的。我想让大家知道，我去看了第二季的幕后花絮。好的。
You guys, they're on YouTube and it's really worth it. Can you see us losing it? There's bloopers of this scene and it is hilarious. I was cracking up watching you guys and also Brian does break in one of them too, but it's mostly you and John breaking, but the bloopers, the outtakes from this are fantastic. Oh my gosh. I have to watch those because that was just my memory. I just remembered when I saw the scene how much John and I couldn't stop laughing.
伙计们，它们在YouTube上，真的非常值得一看。你们能看到我们笑崩了吗？这场戏有幕后花絮，简直太搞笑了。看着你们笑得前仰后合，我也笑疯了，而且布赖恩在其中一个镜头里也笑场了，但主要是你和约翰笑场，不过这段花絮和删减片段简直棒极了。哦，天哪。我得去看看那些，因为那正是我的记忆。当我看到这一幕时，我只记得我和约翰当时根本笑得停不下来。
Okay. We'll look up season two, the office bloopers on YouTube because it's really funny. Also, did you notice that there is a community plate of Doritos on the table? Yes, on a paper plate. What's the story there? I don't know. John bought Doritos, put a paper plate in the middle of the table, and then put the Doritos on the plate for us all to eat.
好吧。去YouTube上搜索第二季的《办公室》幕后花絮，因为真的太搞笑了。还有，你有没有注意到桌上有一盘大家共享的多力多滋（Doritos）薯片？是的，放在一个纸盘子里。这背后有什么故事吗？我不知道。约翰买的多力多滋，把一个纸盘子放在桌子中央，然后把多力多滋倒在盘子里让我们大家吃。
I eat some, John eats some. What is that? I think you guys just shared some Doritos. Yes, we did. I don't think it's that complicated. Have you ever done that in an office? When you're eating lunch with people, you're like, hey guys, who wants to split some Doritos? Oh my gosh.
我吃一些，约翰吃一些。这算什么？我觉得你们俩就是分着吃了点多力多滋。是的，我们吃了。我觉得没那么复杂。你们在办公室里做过这种事吗？当你和大家一起吃午饭时，你会说，嘿，伙计们，谁想分点多力多滋吃？哦，天哪。
Oscar and I shared snacks all the time, Jenna. We would get a bag of chips and we'd share and we would get little paper cups and split snacks into paper cups. We also, like at least once a week, would share a Coke. I can't tell you how many times I would walk over to my desk and Oscar would be like, there's half a Coke for you. I'd be like, thanks, and some chips. I think that I'm a person who always wants a full Coke and a full bag of chips, so I
奥斯卡和我总是分吃零食，珍娜。我们会买一包薯片然后一起吃，我们会拿小纸杯把零食分到纸杯里。我们还经常，至少一周一次，分喝一罐可口可乐。我无法告诉你我有多少次走到办公桌前，奥斯卡会说，这半罐可乐是你的。我会说，谢谢，还有一些薯片。我觉得我是一个总是想要一整罐可乐和一整包薯片的人，所以我
have not experienced this thing you're talking about, this sharing of snacks. Oscar Nunez and I shared snacks and sodas every single week. That is adorable. That is adorable. In fact, sometimes I know I'm going on and on about this. Sometimes one of us would get the Coke and start it, but the other wouldn't be ready, so we'd be like, I put the half Coke in the fridge for you. We'd be like, okay.
没有经历过你说的这种事，这种分吃零食的行为。奥斯卡·努涅斯（Oscar Nunez）和我每周都会分吃零食和苏打水。太可爱了。太可爱了。事实上，有时候我知道我一直在唠叨这个。有时候我们中的一个人会拿一罐可乐并打开它，但另一个人还没准备好，所以我们会说，我把半罐可乐放冰箱里给你留着。我们就会说，好的。
So we would know. We'd sort of hide it in the back. This is absolutely adorable. Meanwhile, I'm just over at my desk chugging my full Coke. Your full soda. I had a question for you about this scene. Okay. At seven minutes, 48 seconds, Pam says the professors would go to the parties and Michael
所以我们会心照不宣。我们会把它藏在最里面。这绝对太可爱了。与此同时，我正坐在办公桌旁吨吨吨地狂灌我那一整罐可乐。你那整罐苏打水。关于这场戏，我有个问题想问你。好的。在7分48秒，帕姆说教授们会去参加派对，然后迈克尔
goes, yeah, they were the most fun. Jenna, how did you get through that line? I know you said you were laughing a lot, but like, I didn't get through any line in that scene. That line would be so hard for me to say because it's coming off of him being so ridiculous. Also, the whole time he's eating those dang noodles. So I just, it was, I have to go back. I want to watch the deleted.
就说，对啊，他们最会玩了。珍娜，你是怎么把那句台词说下来的？我知道你说你当时笑得很厉害，但是，我在这场戏里一句台词都没顺下来。那句台词对我和来说太难说了，因为这紧接着他那些荒谬的话后面。而且他一直在吃那些该死的面条。所以我只能，我得回去看看。我想看被删掉的。
Well, what is it? The bloopers. You got to watch the bloopers. At eight minutes, two seconds, you guys. Let me find out what Jim thinks are the three ingredients for a great party. Number one, three cases of imported beer. Number two, karaoke machine. Number three, do not invite Michael.
好吧，那是什么？花絮。你们得去看花絮。伙计们，在8分02秒。让我看看吉姆认为一个好派对的三大要素是什么。第一，三箱进口啤酒。第二，卡拉OK机。第三，不要邀请迈克尔。
Yeah. I mean, he's probably not wrong. All right. At eight minutes, 25 seconds, the camera crew helps Pam. I know. The camera rushes over to her desk and indicates that she should look over to Dwight, who she discovers is eating a baby roof bar, the one that Angela bought. That's right.
对。我是说，他大概没说错。好吧。在8分25秒，摄像机组帮了帕姆。我知道。摄像机冲向她的办公桌，暗示她应该看看德怀特，她发现德怀特正在吃一根贝比露丝糖果棒，也就是安吉拉买的那根。没错。
I have that you are in cahoots. In cahoots. Pam and the cameraman are in cahoots. So first, Pam takes the step of talking directly to the camera crew, and now the camera crew has gotten involved. That's a big deal. I'm surprised that we did this so early in the series. When I was watching this, we're not that far in for us to be involving the crew like
我记着你们是一伙的。是一伙的。帕姆和摄像师是一伙的。所以首先，帕姆采取了直接与摄像机组对话的行动，现在摄像机组也参与进来了。这可是一件大事。我很惊讶我们在剧集这么早期的时候就这么做了。当我观看这一集时，我们才播到没多久，就让摄制组这样参与进来。
this. We should know that our camera operator was Randall Einhorn. He's also our DP. He went on to direct a bunch of episodes, and I had a really special relationship with Randall, and I remember filming the scene with him. He was really performing for me. He would come over and he'd have a big smile on his face and a twinkle in his eye, and he would motion over.
我们应该知道，我们的摄像师是兰德尔·艾恩霍恩（Randall Einhorn）。他也是我们的摄影指导。他后来导演了许多集，我和兰德尔有着非常特殊的联系，我记得和他一起拍这场戏的情景。他当时真的在为我表演。他会走过来，脸上带着灿烂的笑容，眼中闪烁着光芒，然后打手势。
He would give me a little thumbs up. So all this interaction was happening. I felt like we were really performing together, and he was playing the character of the camera person. So I just have really fond memories of working with Randall in general. When Pam would have really emotional scenes, sometimes I would look at him and he would be teared up. No, he's got a big heart, and he wears it on his sleeve, and we all got really attached
他会给我比个大拇指。所以所有这些互动都在发生。我觉得我们真的在共同表演，而他在扮演摄像师这个角色。所以我对和兰德尔合作总是有着非常美好的回忆。当帕姆有非常情绪化的戏份时，有时候我会看着他，发现他眼眶都湿润了。不，他有一颗善良的心，而且喜怒形于色，我们所有人其实都对兰德尔产生了深厚的感情。
to Randall. And I just think of him as sort of this very charming blue-eyed terminator. Because you guys, you only ever see one of his eyeballs because the other eyeball is looking through the lens. Yeah. So you see this one blue eye emoting emotion, and you're like, aw, you're like the friendly terminator. The friendly terminator.
我觉得他就像是那种非常迷人的蓝眼睛终结者。因为伙计们，你永远只能看到他的一只眼球，因为另一只眼球正通过镜头在看呢。对。所以你看到这只蓝色眼睛在表达情绪，你就会想，哇，你就像个友好的终结者。友好的终结者。
At nine minutes, 29 seconds, you guys, aw, Jim, you just break my heart all the time. But he's trying to be sly. He's trying to do that thing where he figures out, is Roy going to come, but he's trying to play it cool. So he's like, yeah, I just need a head count. Yeah. Is Roy going to be there tonight? You know why? It's just because I need to know how many burgers to make.
在9分29秒，伙计们，哦，吉姆，你总是让我心碎。但他正试图表现得狡猾。他正试图表现出那种试图弄清楚罗伊会不会来的样子，但他又想表现得很酷。所以他说，对啊，我只是需要确定一下人数。对。罗伊今晚会去吗？你知道为什么吗？只是因为我需要知道要做多少个汉堡。
Yeah. I mean, this is the subtext, right? It's nothing else. It's not because I love you and I want you to be in my apartment without your fiancé. Yeah. Wait, is he? Yeah, he's still your fiancé. He is.
对。我的意思是，这才是潜台词，对吧？没有别的。不是因为我爱你想让你在没有未婚夫的情况下在我的公寓里。对。等等，他是吗？对，他还是你的未婚夫。他是。
I know. It's hard to remember, right? Fan question from Juan Martinez. Was Roy really unable to attend the party, or did Pam ditch him so she could hang out with Jim? I don't think she ditched him, and I don't think she lied to him. Yeah. I don't think Pam was just as excited that Roy couldn't attend as Jim is.
我知道。很难记住，对吧？胡安·马丁内斯（Juan Martinez）的粉丝提问。罗伊是真的无法出席派对，还是帕姆甩了他好去和吉姆混在一起？我不认为她甩了他，我也不认为她对说了谎。对。我不认为帕姆和吉姆一样，对罗伊无法出席感到那么高兴。
Yeah. I think Roy probably has some dude hang out. He's kind of a dude, dude, right? Yeah. And he probably has his thing. And also, Roy wouldn't want to go. I was going to say, the last thing Roy wants to do is hang out with any of the Dunder Mifflin employees.
对。我觉得罗伊大概有他自己的一帮哥们儿要聚。他挺大男子主义的，对吧？对。他大概有他自己的活动。而且，罗伊才不想去呢。我本来想说，罗伊最不想做的事就是和任何邓德米夫林的员工混在一起。
Yeah. He's sort of over it. They have to do enough of that probably for him. So he was, I think, happy to sit this one out, and Pam was like, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. And so was Jim. He was like totally making this up. But maybe Pam waited kind of till the last minute to tell Roy about the party so that
对。他有点腻了。他大概得陪他们应付够多了。所以我认为，他很乐意缺席这次派对，而帕姆则是一副，哦天哪，哦天哪，哦天哪的样子。吉姆也是。他完全是瞎编的。但也许帕姆等到了最后一分钟才把派对的事告诉罗伊，这样
it would be less likely that he could attend. Like I could see her maybe doing that. And I could see her downplaying it like, oh, you know, I don't know, it's the thing I have to go to. Everyone's going. Yes. 100%. It's going to be lame.
他就更有可能无法出席了。我觉得她可能会这么做。我能想象她会轻描淡写地说，哦，你知道的，我也不知道，这是我得去的一个活动。大家都去。是的。百分之百。会很无聊的。
You know what? If you don't want to go, you don't have to. Yeah, it's fine. I'll go because I feel like I have to, but I don't want you to have to change your plans. I totally get it if you don't want to go. It's okay. 100% how that went down, I believe. Yes.
你知道吗？如果你不想去，你不去也行。对，没关系。我会去，因为我觉得我不得不去，但我不想让你改变你的计划。如果你不想去，我完全理解。没关系。我相信事情百分之百就是这样发展的。是的。
All right. So now everyone's trying to get out of the office and they're trying to avoid Michael because they all know he's not invited. So people are making up excuses to not hang out with him that night. And Angela, you have a great one. You say charity, bake, drive. Oh yeah. I'm sure my character's like horrible at lying.
好吧。所以现在每个人都想离开办公室，他们都在试图避开迈克尔，因为他们都知道他没有被邀请。所以人们都在编造借口，好不跟他一起度过那个晚上。安吉拉，你编了一个绝佳的借口。你说慈善义卖烘焙活动。哦，是的。我敢肯定我的角色撒谎技术烂透了。
Horrible. Well, a lot of people wrote in to ask if our excuses were scripted or improvised. So was yours scripted or improvised? Mine is a combo. So my scripted line was charity, bake, drive, and then Michael's scripted line was liar. And then Steve improvised, you are a liar. And then I improvised, no, I'm not as I left. And I didn't even look back and it stayed in.
烂透了。嗯，很多人写信来问我们的借口是剧本里写的还是即兴发挥的。所以你的借口是剧本写的还是即兴的？我的结合了两者。剧本里写的台词是慈善义卖烘焙活动，然后迈克尔的台词是骗子。接着史蒂夫即兴发挥说，你是个骗子。然后我即兴回答，不，我不是，然后就走了。我甚至都没有回头看一眼，而这段被剪辑保留了下来。
And I think it's great because that's exactly how my character, I think, would have responded. Yes. I just love that Dwight says he is soccer and clarinet practice. Yes. And you know what? I feel like, I feel like sometimes, I mean, you know, we have young children and sometimes when they're bad at lying, they just sort of list what their activities are. So I sort of feel like, like Dwight probably growing up had clarinet and soccer practice
我觉得这太棒了，因为这绝对符合我的角色当时会有所反应的方式。是的。我特别喜欢德怀特说他有足球和单簧管练习。是的。你知道吗？我觉得，我觉得有时候，你知道的，我们有小孩，有时候当他们撒谎技术很烂时，他们就会把自己的活动日程列出来。所以我有点觉得，德怀特成长过程中大概有单簧管和足球练习，
and he just went to default. Also, as Dwight leaves, he says, see you Monday, Michael, casual Friday tracker coming at you. No one's dressed casual. No. No, it's clearly a Friday because he says, see you Monday. None of us are dressed casually, even though we're going to a barbecue after work. Well, people are going to change clothes.
于是他直接就说漏嘴了。另外，德怀特离开时说，周一见，迈克尔，便装星期五追踪器向你走来。没人穿便服。没有。没有，这显然是个星期五，因为他说，周一见。我们谁也没穿便服，尽管我们下班后要去参加烧烤派对。好吧，大家会去换衣服的。
Don't you think they're going to go home and freshen up? I don't want to. Listen, it's still not casual Friday. I get it. I get it. We still set up in a previous episode that we have casual Fridays and yet here it is a Friday and none of us are dressed casually. No, you're right.
你不觉得他们会回家梳洗一下吗？我才不要。听着，这仍然不是便装星期五。我懂的。我懂的。我们在之前的一集里已经设定过我们有便装星期五，然而这里明明是个星期五，我们却没有一个人穿便服。不，你说得对。
You're right. I'm going to stay on this. Okay. I think you stay on it. Don't worry, everybody. I'm on it. I'm on it. I'm on casual Friday and we will continue to track Mindy's hair.
你说得对。我要抓住这个不放。好的。我觉得你抓紧不放吧。别担心，各位。我盯着呢。我盯着呢。我盯着便装星期五，我们也会继续追踪明迪（Mindy）的头发。
Don't anyone lose sleep over it. We're on it. Oh, I'm, as you know, obsessed with Mindy's hair. I'm obsessed. I have one thing to say before we go to the party. Yeah. And again, this was like the Sadiq moment in the cold open for me. It's something I thought probably way too much about.
谁也别为此失眠。我们盯着呢。哦，如你们所知，我对明迪的头发着迷了。我太着迷了。在去派对之前我还有一件事要说。对。而且再次重申，对我来说，这就像是开场白里的那个萨迪克（Sadiq）时刻。这件事我想得可能有点太多了。
Wouldn't Jim have known that Michael saw the evite? This is the day he gets access to everyone's emails. Jim clearly sent it to everyone's work email. Yeah. Wouldn't he have known? He knows Michael knows, right? Well, he knows Michael knows, by the way, Michael is behaving, but you're saying as soon as he got access to the emails, the first thought Jim would have would be, oh, no.
难道吉姆不会知道迈克尔看到了那个Evite吗？这就是他获得所有人邮箱权限的那天。吉姆显然把邮件发到了所有人的工作邮箱。对。难道他不会知道吗？他知道迈克尔知道了，对吧？嗯，他通过迈克尔的表现知道迈克尔知道了，但你的意思是，只要他一拿到邮箱权限，吉姆脑子里的第一个想法就会是，哦，不。
The evites there, the evites sitting in everyone's email, he's going to know. Similarly, how did we get all the way to the day of the party before Dwight thinks to mention the party to Michael? There's that scene where Dwight starts bringing up the party and Jim shushes him. And he's like, no, no, no, no, don't say anything. You're telling me, I mean, when did he send out the evite at least a week ago in that whole week? He didn't have to like the shush on Dwight.
Evite就在那儿，Evite正躺在每个人的收件箱里，他会知道的。同样地，怎么会一直拖到派对当天，德怀特才想起跟迈克尔提起这个派对呢？有这样一个场景，德怀特开始提起派对，然后吉姆让他嘘声。他说，不，不，不，不，什么也别说。你在告诉我，我的意思是，他到底是什么时候发出Evite的，至少在一周前吧，在整整一周的时间里？他竟然没有对德怀特做个嘘声的手势。
No, that didn't bump me as much because I feel like, I don't know. I know, I feel like, listen, guys, this isn't all dudes, but I know from my experience with fellas, they probably aren't going to think about the party till the day of, you know, they're not like, it's not like Dwight is like thinking about this party every day. He's got, you know, he's busy. He's busy. He's managing a secret relationship with Angela. Yeah.
不，这倒没让我那么纳闷，因为我觉得，我不知道。我知道，我觉得，听着，伙计们，倒不是说所有男人都这样，但我根据自己与男同胞相处的经验，他们可能直到当天才会想到派对这回事，你知道的，他们不会像……德怀特可不是每天都在想这个派对。他有，你知道的，他很忙。他很忙。他还要忙着和安吉拉维持地下恋情呢。对。
He's tracking yeast infections and Scranton. Yeah. He's got a lot going on. He's got a lot going on. All right. Fair enough. All right, guys, we're going to take a break. And when we come back, we're going to a party, a barbecue at Jim's house.
他在追踪斯克兰顿的酵母菌感染情况呢。对。他有很多事要忙。他有很多事要忙。好吧。有道理。好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下。等我们回来后，我们要去参加一个派对，一个在吉姆家办的烧烤派对。
We're going to tell you all about it. Be ready. You want to lay those out? Do you want to lay them out? I don't want to rush you. She's back. She got some food and the sass is back. You guys, before we went to break, Jenna was getting a little lightheaded because she's
我们会把一切都告诉你们。准备好。你想把它们摆出来吗？你想把它们摆出来吗？我不想催你。她回来了。她吃了一些东西，那种拽劲又回来了。伙计们，在我们休息之前，珍娜有点头晕，因为她
really hungry. Yeah. So if you notice a tonal shift in this last part of the podcast, it's because we took an actual break during our break and we ate a full lunch. We ate. Jenna and I eat lunch together. And it kind of reminds me of how we had lunch every day on the set of the office. I know.
真的很饿。所以如果你注意到这一期播客最后一部分的语调发生了变化，那是因为我们在休息期间真的休息了一下，而且我们吃了顿丰盛的午餐。我们吃了。珍娜和我一起吃了午餐。这有点让我想起我们在《办公室》片场每天一起吃午餐的情景。我知道。
I love it so much. I was just talking to Lee last night where I said, well, he asked me a question. He was watching the episode with me and he said, what's it like for you to watch these episodes again? Does it bring you back? And I said, it really, the flood of memories that come back to me and the most prevalent is how much we laughed together as a cast. And I said, and now I do this podcast with Angela and we laugh the same way when we do
我太喜欢了。我昨晚还在跟李（Lee）聊天，我说，他问了我一个问题，他当时正和我一起看这一集，他说，你再次看这些集有什么感受？这会带你回到过去吗？我说，真的，涌上心头的回忆如潮水般袭来，其中最普遍的感受就是我们作为演员在一起时笑得有多开心。我说，现在我和安吉拉一起做这个播客，当我们做播客和剪辑播客时，我们笑得一模一样，我们吃午餐的方式也一模一样。现在我都要哭了，因为我们刚刚吃完了我们的午餐之一。对。那顿午餐特别棒，珍娜。
the podcast and when we edit the podcast and we eat lunch the same way. And now I'm tearing up because we just had one of our lunches. Yeah. That lunch in particular, Jenna. It was a good one. It was a good one. And it really reminded me, we navigated nine years of our lives. A lot happened to both of us and we shared a lot at lunch.
那是一次很好的午餐。它真的提醒了我，我们度过了人生中的九年时光。我们俩经历了许多事情，我们在午餐时分享了许多。有些日子只是微不足道的小事。然后有些日子我们会有深刻的心灵对话，而珍娜和我刚才就进行了一次非常深入的心灵对话。那些午餐就像，有时候它们就像是一场治疗。它们比治疗还要好，因为那是你的闺蜜。
And some days it was just little tiny things. And then some days we had huge heart to hearts and Jenna and I just now had a really pretty big heart to heart. Those lunches were like, sometimes they're like a therapy session. They're better than a therapy session because it's your BFF. It's your BFF. That's right. All right.
那是你的闺蜜。没错。好吧。我们回来了，伙计们。我们吃饱了。好的。我要从一个粉丝提问开始。来吧。怎么样？来自罗布·鱼（Rob Fish）。好的。
We're back guys. We're full of food. Okay. And I'm going to start with a fan question. Do it. How about that? From Rob Fish. Okay.
吉姆家烧烤派对用的是谁的房子，因为没错，我们要去吉姆家的这个烧烤派对。关于这栋房子，我们是在北加州的一个真实社区里拍摄的。它不是布景，我们必须采用非常不寻常的拍摄时间，因为这是一场夜戏，窗外必须是真正的夜景。当我们拍邓德米夫林的戏时，我们通常从早上6点拍到晚上6点。但在这里，我们真的拍到了更晚，现在他们，如果他们向屋内拍摄，窗外是什么并不重要，他们可以把窗户用黑布挡上。但对于所有那些外景镜头，确实已经是深夜了，有些晚上我们待到了晚上10点以后。你们还记得我们当时有点累了吗？对。
Whose house was used for Jim's barbecue because that's right, we're go to this barbecue at Jim's house. So for the house we shot in a real neighborhood in Northern California. It wasn't a set and we had to have really unusual shooting hours because it was a night shoot and there was really nighttime outside of the windows. So we usually would shoot from like 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. when we were shooting at Dunder Mifflin. But here we were really shooting more in the evening and now they, if they were shooting
到了晚上9点，我们开始有点精神恍惚了。这是自邓迪奖（Dundee's）以来，我们第一次在片场之外拍摄，真正的外景拍摄。每次我们这样做时总是玩得很开心。对。而且我也记得，在场景之间，其实没有什么地方可供你待着。不。我不记得我们的演员休息车停在那里。不。
into the house, it didn't matter what was outside, they could black out the windows. But for all those shots outside, it was really night and some nights we stayed past 10 p.m. And do you remember we'd get a little bit tired? Yeah. We'd get a little loopy as of 9 p.m. And this was the first time where we shot offset, like really offset since the Dundee's. And we always had a lot of fun when we would do that. Yeah.
我想他们没法把车停在那个社区里。它们离得很远，所以他们用班车把我们接送过去。因此在场景之间，我们大家基本上都挤在那间小客厅里待着。完全是这样。这让我想到了鲁菲奥（Rufio）的一个粉丝提问。他说，当你要上厕所时，你是用房子里的真实卫生间，还是去外景卫生间？我不记得了。但因为很多时候你在住宅里拍摄，他们会用胶带把马桶封上，贴一个小标志，上面写着“请勿使用”。你必须去外面。
And also I remember there wasn't really like a place between scenes for you to go. No. I don't remember our trailers being there. No. I think they couldn't park them in the neighborhood. They were far away, so they would shuttle us in. And so in between scenes, we just really all hung out in that little living room kind of.
他们会在外面搭那种移动厕所。或者他们会租下隔壁的房子，那栋房子就成了大家的休息区。对。也许你可以在那个休息房里小便。我在吉姆的家里上过厕所。哦，不。好吧，我不记得马桶被胶带封上了。我记得他们说我可以去，然后我，你知道的，我迅速地用了，那里
Totally. This leads me to a fan question by Rufio. He said, when you had to go to the bathroom, did you use the actual bathroom in the house or did you go offset? I don't remember. But because a lot of times you shoot in houses and they'll tape the toilet closed and put a little sign on it and it says, do not use. And you have to go outside.
有个走廊卫生间什么的。好吧，有时候他们会允许演员使用房子里的卫生间，但会为剧组人员准备移动厕所，我一直觉得这有点太差劲了。好吧，有一次一个助理导演（AD）向我解释过，因为我当时问，等一下，大家都在用的卫生间在哪儿？她告诉我，他们承担不起让我们走得太远的时间成本。哦，那说得通。所以他们经常会为演员准备一个离得更近的卫生间。
They have like those porta potty things outside. Or they'll rent the house next door and that becomes a holding area for everyone. Yeah. And maybe you can pee in the holding house. I peed in John and Jim's house. Oh no. Well, I don't remember the toilet being taped shut. I remember them saying that I could go and I like, you know, quickly I use, there was
纯粹是因为时间安排。所以大家知道这一点就行了。这样你就不会觉得那么内疚了。我没那么内疚了。对。但这是真的。就像你说的，我们真正的演员休息车可能要坐15分钟的厢型车才能到。所以他们必须想办法让我们去一个离片场更近一点的卫生间。
like a hall bathroom or something. Well, sometimes they would let cast members use the bathrooms in the house, but then they would have porta potty's for the crew, which I always thought was kind of lousy. Well, I know one time it was explained to me by an AD because I was like, well, wait, where's the bathroom everyone's using? And she said to me that they could not afford for us to go too far away. Oh, that makes sense. And so they often would have a bathroom for the actors a little bit closer.
好吧。所以当我们到达派对现场时，吉姆带大家参观他的房子。在我们参观之前。告诉我。有一件事我特别喜欢这种小细节。你们注意到大家的派对服装了吗？等等，我，是的。
Just purely because of timing. So just know that. So you don't feel as bad. I don't feel so guilty. Yeah. But it's true. Like you said, our actual trailers were probably a 15 minute van right away. So they had to create a way for us to go to the bathroom that was a little closer to the
我这里也有。我们能聊聊大家的便装吗？是的。梅雷迪思的打扮就像个机车女郎，还画了烟熏妆。我专门为梅雷迪思准备了一张卡片。好的。好的。她穿着一件牛仔马甲。
set. All right. So when we all get to the party, Jim takes everyone on a tour of his house. Before we go on the tour. Tell me. There is something that I just love little things like this. Did you notice everyone's party attire? Wait, I, yes.
她穿着一件黑色V领衫。露了一点腹部。对。她的头发半扎半放。哦，天哪。她画了非常浓重的烟熏眼线，穿着牛仔裤。她看起来有点像准备去狂欢的样子。我当时觉得，这与大家日常工作装的风格形成了如此鲜明的对比，其中对比最强烈的非梅雷迪思莫属。
I have that here too. Can we talk about everyone's casual clothes? Yes. Meredith is dressed like a biker gal with like a smoky eye. I have a whole card just for Meredith. Okay. Okay. She has a denim vest.
确实。因为她在办公室里总是穿着灯芯绒背带裙。她穿得有点像个褴褛娃娃。她看起来就像穿着一个麻袋，头发散落着，但很显然，派对梅雷迪思开始营业了。她确实如此。那凯文的帽子呢？
She has a black v-neck. She has a little bit of midriff. Yeah. Her hair is half up, half down. Oh boy. She has some very dark smoky eyeliner and jeans. She looks a little bit like she's ready to go party. It is such a striking difference, I thought, of everybody's, the difference between everybody's
哦，他那顶黑色的。是类似费多拉帽（fedora）吗？是吗？那叫什么来着？那不是费多拉帽，但它就像是一顶，对吧？他看起来像1920年代黑帮电影里的老派黑帮分子，对吧？而且他在他的乐队演出时总是戴着这顶帽子。是的，他会的。
casual outfit and their work outfit, the most striking is Meredith. For sure. Like, because she wears like corduroy jumpers to the office. She dresses kind of like a raggedy and doll. She looks like she's in a potato sack and her hair down, but clearly party Meredith comes to play. She does. What about Kevin's hat?
斯克兰蒂城乐队（Scranticity）。是的。这显然是，你知道的，凯文便装时的帽子。他的标志性造型。凯文的未婚夫也在那儿。是的。很多人问，派对上那个金发女人是谁？派对上那个金发女人是谁？
Oh, his black. Is it like a fedora hat? Is it? What is that called? It's not a fedora, but it's like a, right? He looks like an old-timey gangster in like a 1920s movie, right? And he wears it all the time when he's in his band. Yeah, he does.
那是史黛西（Stacy）。史黛西。那是凯文的未婚妻。还有，你们注意到斯坦利的妻子也在那儿吗。她就是坐在斯坦利旁边沙发上的那个深发色女人。是的。好吧。那菲莉丝依然穿着紫色衣服这件事呢？
Scranticity. Yeah. This is clearly, you know, casually Kevin has his hat. His go-to look. And Kevin's fiance is there, too. Yes. A lot of people asked, who's the blonde woman at the party? Who's the blonde woman at the party?
是的。她只穿李子紫。对这个颜色极其忠诚。薰衣草紫。那德怀特穿着勃肯鞋并且说他在车里备了一双备用的这件事呢？对，这很有趣。它们看起来非常新。
It's Stacy. Stacy. It's Kevin's fiance. And also, you notice Stanley's wife is there as well. She's the brunette woman sitting on the couch next to Stanley. Yes. All right. What about the fact that Phyllis is still dressed in purple?
它们看起来……我注意到，我们确认你和德怀特在这集中穿的鞋子是很重要的一步。稍后，你将和吉姆一起参加烧烤派对，然后你会抱怨鞋子上沾了树脂。我简直有太多东西要抱怨了。我踩到树脂了。我是个素食主义者。
Yes. She only wears plum purple. Very committed to that. Lavender. What about the fact that Dwight has on Birkenstocks and says that he keeps an extra pair in his car? Yeah, it's interesting. They look very new.
不。但他们非得写“你踩到树脂了”这句台词的全部原因，是为了让我们把镜头下摇到你的鞋子上，因为确保我们清楚你们俩各自穿的是什么鞋，对后面的剧情发展至关重要。确实如此。确实如此。保罗·费格（Paul Fieg）说过，准备好碰撞勃肯鞋了吗？嘿！
They look... I notice it's an important thing that we establish the shoes that both you and Dwight are wearing in this episode. Later on, you're going to be at the barbecue with Jim, and you're going to complain about getting sap on your shoe. I just have so much to complain about. I stepped in sap. I'm a vegetarian.
碰撞勃肯鞋。没错。所以我想聊聊吉姆带着大家参观他的房子。他太兴奋了。帕姆已经到了。她甚至连大衣都还没脱，他就准备带她参观了。当他们沿着走廊走的时候，首先，顺便说一句，当他们走过走廊时，吉姆的墙上挂着一把画了画的圆锯。
No. But the whole reason they had to write the line that you stepped in sap is so that we can pan down to your shoes, because making sure we know what shoes you guys are each wearing is going to become very important later. It is. It is. Paul Fieg said, are you ready to bump some Birkenstocks? Hey!
这挺受欢迎的。我妈妈就有一把画了画的圆锯。我祖父非常喜欢这个，我们家有几把画了画的锯子。好吧，我有见过画了长锯的，有点像画着长长的风景画，但我对那个有超多疑问。我有。这在东海岸很流行吗？
Bumpin' Birkenstocks. That's right. So I want to talk about Jim taking everyone on the tour of his house. He's so excited. Pam has arrived. She doesn't even have her coat off, and he's ready to take her on this tour. As they're walking down the hallway, first of all, just a side note, as they're walking down the hallway, Jim has a painted circular saw hanging on his wall.
因为，你知道的，既然我来自密苏里州，并且在奥沙克湖（Lake Ozark）度过了很多时间，我见过不少画了画的锯子。但我只是不确定吉姆是在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的哪儿弄到这玩意的。也许这是某个家庭成员传下来的传家宝，因为我曾经得到过一把画了画的圆锯，我把它挂在走廊里，而且还是我自己挂的。我大概，我把它平衡在两根钉子上，然后我有个朋友从我的走廊里笨拙地走过，结果它掉下来了，他们就说，你这是想谋杀我吗，因为我挂得确实不太好，不过就是这样。
That's popular. My mom has a painted circular saw. My grandfather was really into that, and we have a few saws that are painted. Well, okay. I have seen the long saws painted, sort of like a long landscape, but I have so many questions about that. I have. Is that popular on the East Coast?
好吧。我看到了。我觉得这非常有趣，所以喜欢看背景细节的人可以去注意一下。是的。所以无论如何，当他们走过锯子后往台阶上走时，瑞安问凯蒂要不要来，这就是我们得知吉姆和凯蒂不再约会了？他说我已经有一段时间没和她联系了。
Because, you know, being from Missouri and spending a lot of time in Lake Ozark, I've seen plenty of painted saws. But I just wasn't sure where Jim in Scranton, Pennsylvania, got that item. Maybe it was a hand me down from a family member, because I was given a painted circular saw, and I had it in my hallway, and I hung it myself. I sort of like, I sort of balanced it on two nails, and I had a friend who was like kind of clumping through my hallway, and it fell off, and they were like, are you trying to kill me, because I got it, I didn't do a great job hanging it, but there you go.
我知道，但克里斯蒂娜·维洛达塔（Christina Velodata）有一个粉丝提问，瑞安问起凯蒂。吉姆说他有一段时间没和她联系了，所以听起来他们好像分手了，但接着她又出现在了“启航游轮”（Boost Cruise）上。嗯，我觉得他们是分分合合的状态，因为瑞安在接下来的对话中说，你介意我约她出去吗，然后吉姆说，也许我们不该在这里谈这个。对吧？他说类似这样的话。
Well, yeah. I saw that. I thought it was very interesting, so you can check that out, people who like things in the background. Yeah. So anyway, as they're walking up the steps after they've passed by the saw, Ryan asks if Katie is coming, and this is when we learn that Jim and Katie aren't dating anymore? He said I haven't talked to her in a while.
对。所以他有点在回避这个问题。是的。但对我来说，这个回答的意思是，不，瑞安，不要给她打电话。他并没有说，当然啦，老兄，去吧。嗯，当我听到他这么说时，我的理解是他在试图保护凯蒂免受瑞安的骚扰。他可能吧。
I know, but fan question from Christina Velodata, Ryan asked about Katie. Jim says he hasn't talked to her in a while, so it sounds like they've broken up, but then she's on Boost Cruise. Well, I think they're on again off again, because then Ryan in the same conversation says, do you mind if I ask her out, and Jim goes, maybe we won't talk about that right here. Right? He says something like that.
不是那种“我对她感情太深所以我不想让你约她”的感觉，而是更像，“呃，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不”。我的理解是，是的，我其实不知道那边现在是什么情况，我也不太想在帕姆面前谈这个，但我绝对不想让你约她出去。好吧。我接受这个解释。好的。这里还有另一个粉丝提问，这次来自拉蒂曼尼亚（Latimania），我们之前听过她的消息。
Right. So he kind of skirts around the issue. Yeah. But to me, that answer is no, Ryan, don't call her. He didn't say, sure, man, go ahead. Well, when I heard him say that, I interpreted that as being him trying to just protect Katie from Ryan. He might have.
对。所以他有点在回避这个问题。是的。但对我来说，那个回答就是：不，瑞恩，别给她打电话。他没有说，当然，老兄，去吧。嗯，当我听到他这么说时，我的理解是他在试图保护凯蒂免受瑞恩的伤害。他可能吧。
Not like I have such strong feelings for her that I don't want you to call her, but more like, um, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I read it as like, yeah, I don't really know what's going on there, and I don't really want to talk about it in front of Pam, but I certainly don't want you asking her out. Okay. I buy that. Okay. So here's another fan question this time from Latimania, who we have heard from before.
不是那种我对她感情深厚所以不想让你联系她的感觉，更像是，嗯，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。我的解读是，是的，我其实不太清楚那边是怎么回事，我也不太想在帕姆面前谈论这个，但我绝对不想你去约她。好吧，我接受这个说法。好的，这里还有一个粉丝提问，这次来自Latimania，我们之前听过她的声音。
And by the way, I did look at Latimania's insta page and she does amazing fan art of the office. Oh, I'll check it out. So I'm just going to give a shout out, guys, go check out Latimania for some amazing office fan art. How do you spell that? Latimania. L-A-D-A-M-A-N-I-A.
顺便说一句，我确实去看了 Latimania 的 Instagram 主页，她画的关于《办公室》的粉丝艺术作品太棒了。哦，我会去看看的。所以我在这里要大声喊话大家，去 Latimania 的主页看一些超棒的《办公室》粉丝艺术作品吧。那个词怎么拼？Latimania。L-A-D-A-M-A-N-I-A。
Okay. We'll check it out. Okay. She asked, why does Jim have two of the same poster in his place? This was such a good find. Okay. So around 13 minutes, 14 seconds, after the circular saw, they passed by just a pretty generic looking kind of framed poster picture on the wall.
好的。我们会去看看的。好吧。她问，为什么吉姆家里会有两张一模一样的海报？这是一个非常棒的发现。好的。所以大约在 13 分钟 14 秒的时候，圆锯出现之后，他们走过墙上一幅看起来很普通、带框的海报。
When they get up to Jim's bedroom, the same picture is hanging above one of his bookshelves. Clearly, as we've mentioned, we were on a budget and we ran out of decor. I think they just moved it when they shot it. They moved it. I think they moved it, which I think is very, very funny. There might have been something on the wall they needed to cover. Okay. So at this point in the show, we cut from the party back to the improv class.
当他们走到吉姆的卧室时，同一张画正挂在他的一个书架上方。显然，正如我们之前提到的，我们预算有限，而且道具不够用了。我想他们在拍摄时只是把它移了个地方。他们把它移走了。我想他们把它移走了，我觉得这非常非常搞笑。墙上可能有什么东西需要遮挡一下。好的。所以在这个时候，剧情从派对切回了即兴表演课。
Yes. And we're going to see Michael in the improv class for the first time. It's real. He wasn't lying. He really has to go to his improv class. And this is when you find out that Michael just gets out a gun and shoots everybody in every scene he does. Yeah.
是的。我们将第一次看到迈克尔在即兴表演课上的表现。这是真的。他没有撒谎。他真的得去上他的即兴表演课。这就是你发现迈克尔在每个场景中都会掏出一把枪把所有人都射杀的时候。是的。
It's brilliant. He's the worst. He's the worst person to improvise with. And he thinks he's hilarious. And the scene when the teacher says, Michael, I want you to give me all the guns you have is so great. I tried to reach out to Michael Norton because I did a sketch show with him years ago called Balls Out.
这太绝了。他太糟糕了。他是最不适合一起即兴表演的人。而且他觉得自己极其搞笑。当老师说“迈克尔，把你身上所有的枪都交出来”的那场戏真是太棒了。我曾试图联系迈克尔·诺顿，因为几年前我和他一起做过一个名为《Balls Out》的小品秀。
Amazing. And he is such a funny guy. And he played the teacher, right? He played the teacher, Chris. He performs at the Groundlings. You can see him there if you're in Los Angeles. He's also done tons of episodes of Always Sunny in Philadelphia. Oh yeah.
太棒了。他是个极其有趣的人。他扮演的是老师，对吧？他扮演的是老师克里斯。他在 Groundlings 表演。如果你在洛杉矶，你可以在那里看到他。他还参演过大量的《费城永远阳光灿烂》。哦，对。
So you might recognize him from other things. He's a hilarious actor, but he's currently main stage company at the Groundlings as well. I wonder if people at home understand the genius satire of this improv class. As an improviser, were you just dying when you were watching this? I wanted to be in the improv class. I know it wouldn't track for my character, but I was like, oh. I knew a bunch of those people and they're such funny, funny people. So now we go back to the party for the scene, the scene.
所以你可能会在其他作品中认出他。他是个搞笑的演员，不过他目前也是 Groundlings 的主力剧团成员。我想知道家里看节目的观众是否能理解这个即兴表演课的天才讽刺之处。作为一个即兴表演者，你在看这一段时是不是快笑死了？我也想加入即兴表演课。我知道这不符合我角色的设定，但当时我就觉得，哦。我认识这群人中的很多，他们真的是超级无厘头、超级搞笑的人。现在我们要回到派对的那个场景了，那个场景。
Pam is alone in Jim's bedroom. I have so much to say about this because the preparation that went in to any scene with Jim and Pam, it would bring production to a halt. It really would, they were so concerned about getting these scenes right when Jim and I would have to get in a fight or if we had to have these moments up on the roof in this bedroom and we would spend so much time on these. So it's true as a cast member, I'm so sorry. When we would see that there was a big pivotal Jim and Pam scene, we'd be like, oh God, are
帕姆独自在吉姆的卧室里。关于这个我有太多话要说了，因为任何涉及吉姆和帕姆的场景，前期准备工作都会让制作进度停滞不前。真的会这样，他们太关注这些场景的细节了，每当吉姆和我必须吵架，或者我们需要在屋顶、在这个卧室里展现这些时刻时，我们会花大量的时间在这上面。所以这是真的，作为演员，我真的很抱歉。每当看到有吉姆和帕姆的重头戏时，我们就会想，哦天哪，你们
you before it or after it? Oh no. I feel like Phyllis would bring in all of her bills to pay. She'd be like, I need stuff to do. Buckle in. Yeah. Because they're going to just really indulge. Once I became a mom, I didn't mind it.
是在这之前还是之后？哦不。我觉得菲利斯会把她所有的账单都带过来付。她会说，我得找点事做。系好安全带。是的。因为他们会非常投入。当我成为妈妈后，我倒不介意了。
When I saw you guys had a big scene, I'd be like, oh, that means I'm going to go visit my daughter at preschool. Yeah. You'd be like, can I come back to that three-hour break? Well, just know that it was always so important to us to get it right and I remember having long conversations about this scene. So the words that are written in the scene are of no importance. We discussed that what was important was that everything we're not saying, the subtext
当我看到你们俩有大场面时，我会想，哦，那意味着我要去幼儿园看望我女儿了。是的。你会说，我能赶上那个三小时的休息时间吗？好吧，只要知道把事情做好对我们来说永远是那么重要，我记得我们曾就这个场景进行过长时间的讨论。所以场景中写下的台词并不重要。我们讨论过，重要的是那些我们没有说出口的话，即场景的潜台词
of the scene, this is all about Pam being in Jim's bedroom and sitting on his bed. We had to make sure that we very naturally found a way for Pam to sit on his bed and she couldn't just walk in the room and sit on the bed. So she had to start by sitting on his night table and then we had to put the yearbook in exactly the right place so that when she went to grab it, she would most naturally then sit on his bed. And as I was watching this, it brought me back to all of those moments early on in dating and in college or whatever when you walk into that person's bedroom for the first time.
关于这场戏，这完全是因为帕姆在吉姆的卧室里，坐在他的床上。我们必须确保非常自然地找到一个让帕姆坐在他床上的方式，她不能只是走进房间然后直接坐在床上。所以她必须先坐在他的床头柜上，然后我们必须把年鉴放在绝对正确的位置，这样当她去拿它时，她就会最自然地坐在他的床上。而当我看着这一幕时，它把我带回了约会初期以及大学或其他时候，当你第一次走进那个人的卧室时的所有那些时刻。
And you've thought about it for a long time. You've thought about it like, where do they sleep? What does that look like? This is their most intimate room in their house and John is so perfect. If you notice as soon as Pam sits down on the bed, John starts shifting in his desk chair and he looks at her and he immediately looks away, like the fact that she's just sat on his bed, it's almost too much for him. Not only is this woman he's in love with in his room, but now she is in this intimate
而且你已经想了很久了。你一直在想，他们是在哪里睡觉的？那是什么样子的？这是他们家里最私密的房间，而约翰表现得太完美了。如果你注意到，帕姆一在床上坐下，约翰就开始在办公椅上挪动，他看着她，然后立刻把视线移开，就好像她刚刚坐在他的床上这件事，对他来说几乎难以承受。不仅是他深爱的这个女人在他的房间里，而且现在她还在这个私密的地方，
place where she's sitting across from him on his bed as he's probably hoped and thought about for a long, long time. And here's what I love about our show. And I think that this is why people are in love with Jim and Pam and why they respond to them so well is because a lot of times in movies and television shows, when people quote unquote fall in love or you have the couple that is going to fall in love, it seems to kind of be like a lot about sex, right? Like they meet at a bar and then they burst through the door ripping each other's clothes
坐在他对面的床上，正如他可能长期以来一直期望和幻想的那样。这就是我喜欢我们节目的地方。我认为这也是人们深爱吉姆和帕姆、为什么他们对两人的反应如此强烈的原因，因为在很多电影和电视剧中，当人们所谓坠入爱河，或者当你看到即将坠入爱河的那对情侣时，似乎往往和性有很多关系，对吧？就像他们在酒吧相遇，然后冲进门去撕扯彼此的衣服。
off. That never happens really, right? Like that's not really real. Jim and Pam, this moment of them just being in this bedroom, not kissing, not touching, not talking about this stolen moment is more romantic and sexy than that burst through the door ripping each other's clothes off in my opinion. Well the stakes are so high and that's real life. When you really like someone, it's like you can feel your heart beating out of your chest
这在现实中从来没有真正发生过，对吧？那并不是真的很真实。在我看来，吉姆和帕姆在这个卧室里只是待着，没有亲吻，没有触摸，没有谈论这个偷来的时刻，比冲进门去撕扯彼此衣服要浪漫和性感得多。好吧，这里的赌注太高了，这才是真实的生活。当你真正喜欢某个人时，那种感觉就像是你能感觉到你的心在胸口狂跳，
the first time you see a part of them that you've wondered about, their space and where they live. Well, I wrote to break up this beautiful moment, please. When Pam is looking at Jim's yearbook while sitting on his bed, Jim gazes lovingly at her. In this moment, you can see my character's purse on the bed. What? My character always carried this little black clutch, you know?
第一次看到他们身上你一直好奇的一部分，他们的空间和他们居住的地方。好吧，我写信是为了打破这个美好的时刻，求求你了。当帕姆坐在床上看着吉姆的年鉴时，吉姆深情地凝视着她.在这段里，你可以看到我角色的钱包在床上。什么？我的角色总是带着这个黑色的小手拿包，你知道吗？
And it's there on the bed with like a coat. That's what I love too. Yeah. It's that thing you go into someone's house when you're in college or even in your 20s starting out, you're like, oh, you know, you go to a party, there's that one guest room or someone's bedroom. Where you throw your coat on the bed. Where you throw your coat.
它就放在床上的大衣旁边。这也是我最喜欢的地方。是的。这就是你去别人家时的那种感觉，当你在上大学，甚至刚二十出头步入社会时，你会想，哦，你知道，你去参加派对，总会有那个客房或者某人的卧室。把外套扔在床上。把外套扔在床上。
Yes. There's some coats and my purse. I thought it was such a nice touch. Oh, I love that. Look at the little black clutch. That's my purse, Angela Martin's purse. That's a great detail. Well, I remember in addition to the scene, they spent a lot of time planning Jim's bedroom
是的。有一些外套和我的钱包。我觉得这是一个很好的细节。哦，我太喜欢这个了。看那个黑色的小手拿包。那是我的钱包，安吉拉·马丁的钱包。这是一个很棒的细节。好吧，我记得除了这个场景，他们花了很多时间来规划吉姆的卧室
because it was going to be very revealing. And so our set decorator, Michael Gallenberg, he's our set designer. He was in charge of decorating this room under the direction of Paul Feig and Greg Daniels and Jen Salada who wrote the episode. Fan question, Ricky Caden or Caden and Zach McCutcheon both wrote in separately how much of the stuff in Jim's room was actually John Krasinski's, none, none except fan question from Lulu, Katrina, Michael Kemper and many others, was that really John Krasinski's yearbook photo?
因为这会非常具有揭示性。所以我们的布景师迈克尔·加伦堡，他是我们的布景设计师。他在保罗·费格、格雷格·丹尼尔斯和撰写本集的珍·萨拉达的指导下，负责装饰这个房间。粉丝提问，里奇·卡登或卡登以及扎克·麦卡琴都分别写信询问吉姆房间里有多少东西实际上是约翰·克拉辛斯基的，没有，除了来自 Lulu、卡特里娜、迈克尔·肯珀和许多其他人的粉丝提问：那真的是约翰·克拉辛斯基的年鉴照片吗？
Yes. Not his yearbook. They made a fake yearbook page where they superimposed his actual yearbook photo. But there's a lot of interesting stuff in that room. All right, background folks, there's a lot of wonderful little nuggets in Jim's room. I'm sure you noticed, I know I'm probably going to have missed some, but here are some. He has a guitar. Of course he does.
是的。不是他的年鉴。他们制作了一个假的年鉴页面，把他的真实年鉴照片叠加了上去。但那个房间里有很多有趣的东西。好了，背景各位，吉姆的房间里有很多精彩的小彩蛋。我确信你注意到了，我知道我可能会漏掉一些，但这里有一些。他有一把吉他。他当然有。
Okay. Of course he does. But why, of course? I don't know. Have we ever seen him play a guitar? I don't know. But I feel like all the guys that I thought were cool in my 20s had a guitar. Well, I get that.
好吧。他当然有。但为什么说“当然”？我不知道。我们见过他弹吉他吗？我不知道。但我觉得我在二十多岁时觉得很酷的那些男生都有一把吉他。好吧，我懂这个。
That they hardly even played. Well, a fan, Kelsey VZ7 pointed out that in a later episode, you know, when Jim is playing second life, his avatar has a guitar slung over his shoulder. So there's something in Jim that either wishes he played guitar or thought it was cool to play. But we never see him play it, right? No. Correct us guys if we're wrong.
他们甚至很少弹。好吧，粉丝 Kelsey VZ7 指出，在后来的剧集中，你知道，当吉姆在玩第二人生时，他的虚拟形象肩膀上挂着一把吉他。所以吉姆身上有某种东西，要么是他希望自己会弹吉他，要么是觉得弹吉他很酷。但我们从来没见他弹过，对吧？没有。如果错了请纠正我们，伙计们。
I don't think we ever see Jim bust out a guitar. He never takes the stage with Scranton City. No. No. There's a lava lamp. There's the favor poster. On his bulletin board, okay, I want you to know, we hadn't even released an episode yet. A fan wrote into me and said, look at Jim's bulletin board.
我想我们从未见过吉姆突然弹起吉他。他从未和斯克兰顿城乐队一起登台。没有。没有。有一个熔岩灯。还有“支持”海报。在他的公告板上，好吧，我想让你们知道，我们甚至还没播出一集。一个粉丝写信给我说，看吉姆的公告板。
Is that a voodoo doll of Roy? Yes. He has a doll hanging by a noose in what looks like a warehouse shirt. This is crazy. Yeah. Yeah. It's, yeah. We had another fan write in Alston Brown who said, was Jim the Scranton Strangler?
那是罗伊的巫毒娃娃吗？是的。他有一个娃娃挂在绳套里，穿着一件看起来像仓库员工的衬衫。这太疯狂了。是的。是的。这，是的。我们有另一个粉丝奥尔斯顿·布朗写信说，吉姆是斯克兰顿扼喉手吗？
This was perhaps evidence. Yes. What is that? Now listen, I reached out to Michael Gallenberg to ask him about that. He's on vacation. He's on vacation. We'll have to get it as a follow up question. We will because I would love to find out who put that on the cork board.
这也许是证据。是的。那是什么？现在听着，我联系了迈克尔·加伦堡向他询问这件事。他在度假。他在度假。我们得把这作为后续问题再问。我们会的，因为我很想知道是谁把那个钉在软木板上的。
Yeah. We'll have to put that in our candy bag. Yeah. Also, there's like a, some kind of sketch of a motorcycle. It looks like a printout, like what does, does Jim, Jim is starting sound a little bit like a cliche. He has a guitar, he has maybe a motorcycle he wants. Who knows?
是的。我们得把它放进我们的糖果袋里。是的。此外，还有一个，某种摩托车素描。看起来像打印出来的，就像，吉姆，吉姆听起来有点像个老生常谈的俗套人物。他有一把吉他，他可能还想要一辆摩托车。谁知道呢？
Um, there's also, it looks like a card. It says son, like maybe his parents. Aw. I know. Did you see that? It was so sweet. There's some photos. There's a, a little like plaque that says making sense.
嗯，还有一个，看起来像一张卡片。上面写着“儿子”，就像可能是他的父母送的。啊。我知道。你看到了吗？太甜了。有一些照片。还有一个写着“Making Sense”的小饰板。
Okay. What? There's a penguin on his desk. I do love when you pan across over to Pam, you see his CD player. These are the, the tech moments that, tech moments that kind of date us. And then he does take work home a little bit cause there's a Dunder Mifflin catalog on his desk. Wow.
好吧。什么？他的桌子上有一只企鹅。我确实很喜欢当镜头摇向帕姆时，你能看到他的 CD 播放器。这些是带有时代烙印的技术时刻。然后他确实把工作带回家了一点，因为他的桌子上有一本邓德·米夫林的产品目录。哇。
That's good stuff. And I'm sure there's more I miss. So you guys write in. So now we go back downstairs to the party, parties going, everyone's having beer. Now Omi, who played the IT guy, who's also at the party, he gave an interview where he said that we were drinking real beer. I don't remember that. And I wrote it on a card, Jenna.
好东西。我确信还有我漏掉的。所以你们写信告诉我。现在我们回到楼下的派对，派对正在进行，大家都在喝啤酒。现在扮演IT男的奥米也在派对上，他在一次采访中说我们喝的是真啤酒。我不记得了。我把它写在一张卡片上，珍娜。
I did not drink real beer. I, I didn't either. Well, I hate beer. So I had a beer bottle filled with water. So I don't remember that either. Yeah. I don't remember any real beer. No.
我没有喝真啤酒。我，我也没有。好吧，我讨厌啤酒。所以我拿了一个装满水的啤酒瓶。所以我也记不清了。是的。我不记得有什么真啤酒。没有。
That, that feels like it would be unusual for our group. Yeah. They weren't that kind of group. I had water. I know that. Okay. In my beer. All right.
这听起来对我们这群人来说很不寻常。是的。他们不是那种类型的群体。我知道我喝的是水。好的。在我的啤酒里。好的。
And then that's why I said, well, Jesus drank wine. You know, I'm sort of trying to justify it, I guess. But mine was water. Yeah. I did also say in the same interview that they were playing the Xbox 360 and it had games that hadn't been released yet. I remember that. The guys were so excited.
然后这就是为什么我说，好吧，耶稣也喝过酒。你知道，我大概是在试图为此辩解。但我的确实是水。是的。我还在这同一采访中说，他们当时在玩 Xbox 360，里面有尚未发布的游戏。我记得那个。那些家伙太兴奋了。
They were so excited. That I do remember. But the beer, I don't remember. Okay. Did you notice in the kitchen scene with Kelly, Oscar and Stanley, where they're talking about paper. I can see it. Kelly's hair is half up, half down.
他们太兴奋了。这个我确实记得。但啤酒，我不记得了。好的。你注意到在凯莉、奥斯卡和斯坦利谈论纸张的厨房场景中了吗？我能看出来。凯莉的头发半扎半放。
But she's still in a paisley top. But she is more Mindy. She's like, oh, she's a hundred percent Mindy. She's now fully Mindy, but she is. Her wardrobe hasn't caught up. Okay. I feel like at this point, her hair has become unfussed. It's, you know, we're not doing that anymore, but now I kind of want to start tracking her
但她仍然穿着一件佩斯利花纹的上衣。不过她更像是敏迪了。她就像是，哦，她百分之百是敏迪。她现在完全是敏迪了，但她确实是。她的衣橱还没跟上。好的。我觉得此时她的头发已经变得不拘小节了。这，你知道的，我们不再那样做了，但现在我有点想开始追踪她的
wardrobe. Okay, Jenna. Okay. Because I feel like the hair has come down now enough times. I want to see when the wardrobe changes. There is also a scene during the party that I love because it's just one of these things I love about our show is a runner. I love a runner that carries over multiple episodes for many years and Kevin calls Ryan
衣橱了。好的，珍娜。好的。因为我觉得现在头发散下来的次数够多了。我想看看衣橱是什么时候改变的。派对期间还有一个场景我很喜欢，因为这只是我喜欢我们节目的原因之一，那就是一个贯穿线。我喜欢一条贯穿多集甚至多年的贯穿线，凯文把瑞恩叫做
fire guy. Yes. You know? And I just love that. It's stuck. I like that too. So when the karaoke machine gets going, Phyllis is singing karaoke. It was so sweet.
“火男”。是的。你知道吗？我太喜欢这个了。这个梗留下来了。我也很喜欢这个。所以当卡拉OK机启动时，菲利斯在唱卡拉OK。太甜了。
Phyllis was so charming. Do you remember filming that? I do. And I wrote about it in my journal. You really journaled hard on this episode. This was a big journal episode for me. Oh, okay. I wrote this.
菲利斯太迷人了。你还记得拍摄那个场景吗？我记得。我在日记里写过。你在这集里真的是疯狂写日记。对我来说，这是一集有大量日记内容的剧。哦，好吧。我写了这个。
Oh my gosh. When Phyllis had to do the karaoke scene, we were all losing it. We started laughing so hard. First of all, she had to sing White Snakes Here I Go Again and she had never even heard of White Snake. Oh my gosh. The production staff got her a copy of the song and she walked around for days listening to it and practicing.
哦，天哪。当菲利斯不得不演卡拉OK的场景时，我们所有人都笑疯了。我们笑得太厉害了。首先，她得唱白蛇乐队的《Here I Go Again》，而她甚至都没听说过白蛇乐队。哦，天哪。制作组给她弄了一份这首歌的副本，她连续好几天到处走都在听并练习。
She was so cute and she was really nervous, but I thought she was brilliant. That is amazing. I love this image of Phyllis walking around listening to White Snake. Incidentally, that album was the first record album I ever bought, like actual record album as a teenager was White Snake. Oh my gosh. And I would listen to it all the time. My first tape cassette I ever bought was Ario Speedwagon.
她太可爱了，而且真的很紧张，但我认为她表现得太精彩了。这太棒了。我脑海里浮现出菲利斯戴着耳机，一边走一边听白蛇乐队的画面。顺便说一句，那张专辑是我买的第一张唱片专辑，作为一个十几岁的小孩，我买的第一张真正的唱片专辑就是白蛇乐队的。哦，天哪。我以前经常听。我买的第一盒磁带是 REO Speedwagon 乐队的。
Oh. Heard it from a friend who, heard it from a friend who, heard it from another you've been messing around. Okay, we can't sing anymore. Okay. We can't sing. We can't pay for that. Also, no one wants to hear that.
哦。听到朋友说，听到朋友说，听到另一个朋友说你一直在胡闹。好吧，我们不能再唱了。好吧。我们不能唱歌。我们付不起版权费。而且，没有人想听那个。
Also, no one wants to hear that. But imagine sweet, adorable Phyllis walking around, here I go again on my own with like a headset on. Well, do you remember that music video with that Tawny, Tawny, all over the hood of the car. The redheaded lady, just crazy. She did the splits on a car, in a dress. Yeah.
另外，也没有人想听那个。但想象一下甜美可爱的菲利斯，戴着耳机，一边走一边唱着“here I go again on my own”。好吧，你还记得那个音乐录影带吗，托妮，托妮趴在车引擎盖上。那个红头发的女人，太疯狂了。她穿着裙子在车上劈叉。是的。
Okay. You know what? No judgment. Now, tell me, when do you go outside with Dwight? There's a moment where I slip outside. No one notices. Yeah. And then if you're watching the scene inside, I'm in it on the couch.
好吧。你知道吗？不予置评。现在，告诉我，你是什么时候和德 Dwight 一起走到外面的？有一个场景我溜到了外面。没有人注意到。是的。然后如果你看里面的场景，我在沙发上。
Yeah. Right? Well, when Michael crashes the party, you're inside. I'm inside. Yeah. That's right. And then all of a sudden, as the party gets going, you don't see me or Dwight. Well, this is what's a little curious for me, because Michael crashes the party and
是的。对吧？嗯，当迈克尔大闹派对时，你在里面。我在里面。是的。没错。然后突然之间，随着派对的进行，你看不到我或德怀特了。嗯，这对我来说有点奇怪，因为迈克尔大闹派对时
you're inside. And then he starts singing Islands in the Stream, a duet. Jim saves him, which is very charming. And then I just need to point out, by the way, Steve starts to harmonize, like, real well. I know. In that song. I know.
你在里面。然后他开始唱《Islands in the Stream》，一首二重唱。吉姆救了他，这非常迷人。然后我需要指出的是，顺便说一句，史蒂夫开始非常完美地进行和声。我知道。在那首歌里。我知道。
It's really pretty great. But I also want to point out that when he crashes the party, Jim and Pam are always sitting next to each other at the party. They are. They track us. We're on some chairs. Then we're on the couch together. We are making sure to maximize this party for, like, maximum next to each other time.
真的非常棒。但我也想指出，当他大闹派对时，吉姆和帕姆在派对上总是坐在一起。他们确实如此。他们追踪着我们。我们坐在一些椅子上。然后我们一起坐在沙发上。我们确保最大限度地利用这个派对，创造尽可能多地坐在一起的时间。
You're sitting next to each other. The other thing I noticed throughout the party is that Jim's roommate and his girlfriend are all over each other. They're constantly making out. They're making out. Or she's sitting on his lap, or she has a leg, like, over his leg. And to say, those two people did not know each other before they started filming. And I mean, what is that job?
你们坐在一起。我在派对上注意到的另一件事是，吉姆的室友和他的女朋友一直黏在一起。他们一直在亲热。他们在亲热。要么她坐在他的大腿上，要么她的腿搭在他的腿上。顺便说一句，这两个人在开始拍摄之前并不认识彼此。我的意思是，那是什么工作？
How do you get, I mean, I would feel so shy if I was, that was my job. I was like, hi, nice to meet you. I guess we're just going to hang on to each other all day for tonight while we shoot this thing. Back to the scene, Steve and John as Jim and Michael are harmonizing islands in the stream. And then in the background, we go over their shoulder and we slowly push in on Angela's feet and Dwight's feet bumping the Birkenstocks. All right.
你怎么能，我的意思是，如果那是我的工作，我会觉得太害羞了。我会想，嗨，很高兴认识你。我想今天晚上为了拍这个东西，我们得一整天都挂在对方身上了。回到这个场景，史蒂夫和约翰饰演的吉姆和迈克尔在合唱《Islands in the Stream》。然后背景中，镜头越过他们的肩膀，慢慢推向安吉拉和德怀特的脚，勃肯鞋碰在一起。好吧。
Let's break down this scene for a second. I have to tell you some behind the scenes. Okay. I have some fan questions as well. Well, ask them. Perhaps they'll lead you in. Maybe they're part of my note cards. Well, this is not a fan question.
我们来剖析一下这个场景。我必须告诉你们一些幕后花絮。好的。我也有一些粉丝提问。那就问吧。也许它们能引导你。也许它们在我的记事卡里。好吧，这不是粉丝提问。
This is a me question. What are you in? Is it a shed? Is it a doghouse? It seems too small to be a shed and too large to be a doghouse. What is it? It looked like a giant dollhouse that people would buy for their little girl. There was like a ramp of steps that went up to it.
这是我的问题。你在什么里面？是个棚子吗？是个狗窝吗？它看起来作为棚子太小了，作为狗窝又太大了。那是什么？它看起来像人们会给小女孩买的巨大玩具娃娃屋。有一道台阶坡道通往里面。
It looked like someone had bought this for their little girl to play in, like a fancy dollhouse. Yeah. Well, Angela, I have a fan question now. A-Town and Nat Attack and Brooklyn Jade all want to know, was that really rain and Angela making out or were they just random stunt people wearing the same shoes? And if it was them, did they talk? How did they make it not weird?
看起来像是有人买这个给他们的小女孩玩，就像一个豪华的娃娃屋。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我有一个粉丝提问。A-Town、Nat Attack 和布鲁克林·杰德都想知道，那真的是雨和安吉拉在亲热，还是他们只是穿着同样鞋子的随机特技替身？如果是他们，他们说话了吗？他们是怎么做到不尴尬的？
I mean, yeah, I think we all just want to know. Okay. How did that go down? All right. Okay. So of course it's weird. It's totally weird. It was rain and I, we did not kiss guys.
我是说，是的，我想我们大家都想知道。好吧。那是怎么进行的？好吧。好的。所以这当然很尴尬。这完全很尴尬。我和雨并没有接吻，伙计们。
We did not make out. In fact, it was really cold out in that dollhouse. So I had on a big thick coat. I had hand warmers, but they did want to see our Birkenstocks a bump in. It was a little tricky because we had to time it out perfectly and we tried different positions of our feet. Here's the thing. Jane Wilson is six, three, I am five, one, so my feet did not hang out of the dollhouse.
我们没有亲热。事实上，那个娃娃屋外面非常冷。所以我穿着一件又大又厚的羽绒服。我有暖手宝，但他们确实想看到我们的勃肯鞋互相碰撞。这有点棘手，因为我们必须完美地掌握时间，我们尝试了脚的不同位置。事情是这样的。雷恩·威尔逊身高六尺三寸，我身高五尺一寸，所以我的脚根本挂不到娃娃屋外面。
Oh my gosh. Yeah. If your bodies were positioned so that you could actually be kissing one another, we would never see your feet. No. No. So we tried our feet in a few different positions so the camera could see them both. We were laying side by side, kind of flipping our feet back and forth.
哦，天哪。是的。如果你们的身体位置设计成真的可以互相亲吻，我们就永远看不到你们的脚了。不。不。所以我们尝试了把脚放在几个不同的位置，以便摄像机能同时看到它们。我们并排躺着，有点像把脚来回翻转。
Okay. Paul Feig was like, you guys kind of look like you're doing a sad breaststroke swim or something. He was like, I don't know what you're doing. It looks like you're swimming. So he was like, all right, how do I say this? This is somewhat awkward, Angela, but I think you need to lay on your back and straddle rain. Like I was like, what?
好的。保罗·费格说，你们俩看起来有点像在做一个悲伤的蛙泳什么的。他说，我不知道你们在干什么。看起来像在游泳。所以他说，好吧，我该怎么说呢？这有点尴尬，安吉拉，但我想你需要仰面躺着，跨坐在雷恩身上。当时我就想，什么？
And he said, yeah. He said, I'd love to see your little feet wrap around his calves and rub back and forth. So in order for me to do this, you guys, my face was in his chest. Were you to see my feet? Were you like suffocating? Kind of. I'm imagining. Like how are you breathing?
他说，对。他说，我很想看到你的小脚丫盘在他的小腿上，来回摩擦。所以为了让我做到这一点，伙计们，我的脸贴在他的胸口。你能看到我的脚吗？你当时快窒息了吗？有点。我可以想象。你当时是怎么呼吸的？
Rain was also doing sort of like this painful kind of plank move so that he didn't crush you. So he didn't crush me so I could breathe and then I was like, how do I wrap my feet around his calf? It's kind of awkward. You know why? Your ankles don't bend that way. Your shins don't bend that way.
雷恩也摆出了一种痛苦的平板支撑姿势，这样他就不会压垮你。为了不压垮我，让我能够呼吸，然后我就想，我怎么把脚盘在他的小腿上？这有点尴尬。你知道为什么吗？你的脚踝不能那样弯曲。你的小腿胫骨不能那样弯曲。
So I was doing this weird on action rainwood rollover on top of me do his weird plank move like it. And one take kind of took a long time. You started to shake a little. Oh dear. All I will say is rain, you're a very strong guy, but planking does take a toll on people. Take after take. We did a bunch of takes.
所以我就在做这个奇怪的动作，雷恩不得不翻身压在我身上，摆出他那奇怪的平板支撑姿势，就像那样。而且一个镜头拍了很长时间。你开始有点颤抖了。哦天哪。我只想说，雷恩，你是个非常强壮的人，但平板支撑对人来说确实是个消耗。一条又一条。我们拍了好多条。
Also my feet were like in this weird position. So we did this every take and in between takes we would roll on our backs side by side. We would have these really deep conversations. It was just one of those surreal moments where we were doing the most ridiculously silly thing and then in between we talked about like our lives. I feel like this is the moment where I really became friends with rain because we talked about where we grew up and our childhoods and like what we believed in and just really had this really huge heart to heart in between this plank straddle foot rubbing of the calf.
另外我的脚一直处于这种奇怪的姿势。所以我们每条都这么拍，在拍摄间隙我们会并排躺在背上。我们会进行非常深入的对话。这只是那种超现实的时刻之一，我们在做着最荒谬愚蠢的事情，而在间隙里我们却在谈论我们的生活。我觉得这就是我和雷恩真正成为朋友的时刻，因为我们谈论了我们的成长经历、我们的童年以及我们的信仰，在平板支撑跨坐摩擦小腿的间隙，真的进行了一次非常深刻的交心。
I did write about this in my journal as well. And I just said that I was really glad they weren't rolling sound out there. We weren't miked because I was giggling so much whenever we had to rub beat. So that kind of is the end of the episode. That ends the episode. There's a little tag where we go back to the improv class. It's a little bit of a flashback. I think that they just loved this monologue, this talking head that Steve gives so much
我在日记里也写过这个。我只是说我很高兴外面没有在收音。我们没有带麦克风，因为每当我们不得不摩擦脚时，我都咯咯笑得太厉害了。所以这差不多就是这集的结尾了。这集到此结束。有一个小彩蛋，我们回到了即兴表演课。这是一个小小的闪回。我想他们太喜欢这个独白了，也就是史蒂夫贡献的这段内心独白
that they had to include it at the end of the episode. But I don't know if you remember this, Angela, that last night when we shot, we stayed till after midnight. It was a really late night and I also wrote this in my journal. I said, Steve ordered pizzas for the cast and crew and we all had like a little bitty like kind of, I guess, mini party after the party. He ordered Barone's pizza. Yeah.
以至于他们不得不在剧集末尾把它包含进来。但安吉拉，我不知道你是否还记得，我们拍摄的那天晚上，一直待到半夜之后。那是一个非常晚的夜晚，我也把这个写进了日记。我说，史蒂夫为演员和剧组订了比萨，我们在派对结束后都有了一个小小的，呃，我猜是迷你派对。他订了巴罗内的比萨。是的。
His favorite. His favorite was so good and that was really cool. I love that we kept journals. Even in our 30s, journaling. We were 80 when we were 30. We're almost to our appropriate age. I think so. All right, guys.
他的最爱。他的最爱，太棒了，真的太酷了。我很高兴我们坚持写日记。甚至在我们三十多岁的时候还在写日记。我们三十岁的时候就像八十岁一样。我们快要达到我们合适的年龄了。我想是的。好了，伙计们。
Thank you so much. We cannot wait. Next week is the Christmas episode, the first Christmas episode and we have a lot to say. Yankee swap. Thank you so much, Ken Jong, Joel McHale, not so much and we'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher.
非常感谢。我们迫不及待了。下周是圣诞节特辑，第一部圣诞节特辑，我们有很多话要说。洋基交换礼物。非常感谢，郑肯，乔尔·麦克海尔，没那么感谢，我们下周见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是里德·勃拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要获取该节目的无广告版本以及我们的糖果袋花絮节目，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。